we are not going to EXA anything today
and this bill is going to
subcommittee the rule subcommittee will
be working on Section
seven and tomorrow we meeting tomorrow
at
10 pensions committee is going to work
on Section Five and their meeting
tomorrow at
go um it's the representative Roy's
committee is going to meet tomorrow
afternoon and the rest of the bill will
be covered
by Michael
yakubovich's subcommittee and they will
Thursday don't know which subcommittee
note when will that
be the
which part you said you'll you'll send
us a notice and and when will that be
done the actually Miriam has already
sent out the calendar notices for all
three of the meetings which lists the
subcommittee members so you can just
that that that that works fine thank you
very much Madam chair okay and actually
representative Schmidt you're with
representative Pearson and your meeting
on the 7th on Senate Bill 58
well we will not be as I said executing
anything today we will be doing this
section by
section so that we can remember what the
sponsor has to say while we while we
listen to anyone else who's interested
and then we will no that's great that's
a very good procedure thank
you most of these sections have nothing
whatsoever to do with it with the each
yeah
now it's now 10 o'clock I will open the
hearing on Senate
Bill 133 and I will read our
script okay as chair of the house Edna
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number two
number 12 sorry first went to executive
order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet Electronics this is a public
hearing on bills referred to the
committee and scheduled in the house
calendar for
today an executive session may be held
on any Bill referred to the committee
please not there's no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and invited
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS
l.n. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled all
votes that are taken dur during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
we'll start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their present please also State whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
no okay representative algro here in the
room representative Bailey here in the
Fellows Home
Alone
representative
funno not yet representative
goalie here at home and my wife is in
the other
room representative
Broda here in my home office alone
representative
Judy
no no uh representative
Lara mobile and nashille and I am
alone representative
leus he stepped out he stepped up but he
O'Brien uh representative
Pearson
representative
Roy repres representative Santo
naso uh home alone
here representative
Schmidt I am at my uh home office in
Dover and I'm
alone representative sh is I'm at my
home in pemro
alone representative Schulz good morning
I'm in conquered at my home and my
husband Jean Taylor will be in and out
of the room the Clark is here in the
room representative
yakovich home alone in the
room let me run through and see whether
representative uh funno is here
representative Judy representative leus
is we understand sorry representative
O'Brien he's there representative
O'Brien's here and I'm a home alone n
thank you representative Pearson
representative
okay we have three abenes at the moment
thank you all right uh in that case I'm
opening the hearing and I call Senator
Carson good morning Madam chair uh for
the record my name is Sharon Carson and
I have the pleasure of representing
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of London da Hudson and Auburn and I
have this morning for your consideration
Senate Bill
133 which seeks to adopt Omnibus
legislation relative to occupational
licensure um Madam chair I will go there
are 13 sections of this bill and I will
introduce um each
section ior I'm sorry Senator we're
going to go Section by section so if you
would just introduce section one for
which you are the prime sponsor and then
we'll uh and any other points you wish
to make but not specifically introducing
each
section okay thank you uh thank you very
much for that clarification Madam chair
um section one deals with licensing
places of assembly this is a refile of
Senate Bill 432 which is filed in 2020
which passed the Senate but died on the
table in the house during the uh
covid-19 pandemic um what this bill
essentially does is allows the Fire
Marshall office to issue a license for a
place of assembly in situations where
there is not a local authority to do so
um or when they may ask the fire
Marshall's office to provide a license
thank you very much Madam chair thank
none
I
believe uh Paul parzy is wishes to speak
sir
okay thank you Mr freezy when you're
with us please unmute
and give us your your
wisdom good morning Madam chair can you
hear me yes good morning Madam chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Paul paresi it's my privilege
to serve as the State Fire Marshall I'm
here today in support of Senate Bill 133
section one uh which as Senator Carson
uh stated it does allow us to issue uh
us meaning State fir maral's office to
issue a place of assembly licenses in
the event that it's necessary to do so
uh typically place of assembly licenses
are issued by the local Authority having
jurisdiction um uh for your edification
places of assembly are rooms or spaces
where more than uh 100 people congregate
or 50 or more if it's a tent um
currently when the authority having
jurisdiction uh when there is no
Authority having jurisdiction such as
places like green Grant or the summit of
Mount Washington or dicksville Notch um
and there is no Board of Selectmen
available to uh issue a place of
assembly um there needs to be somebody
to be able to do that and currently no
one can so uh we filed this legislation
in the hopes that at least the the State
Fire Marshal's office would be able to
do so and um and then also in
consultation with us in the event that
uh there a local Authority having
jurisdiction uh there are times when
it's more prudent for us to issue it
than them so that's the purpose of the
legislation I thank Senator KAS for
introducing it and thank you for
allowing me to
question thank you um Fire Marshall
paresi how is this
enforced thank you for the question
representative it's typically enforced
by the local Authority having
jurisdiction
um it is part of the state laww so the
local Authority having jurisdiction
would uh would make sure that it's
enforced in in the event that um there
is no local Authority having
jurisdiction than than we would but this
would clean it up so that not only could
we enforce it but we could also issue
the
permit thank you you're welcome there
committee seeing none is there anyone
one if you do please raise your hand and
listen Okay seeing
none close the testimony from section
one and move on to section two I will
call senator rosenal
who is the Prime sponsor of section
two and remind representative goalie
O'Brien and Pearson that they are our
co-sponsors and will not be asking
questions thank you good morning Madame
chair and members of the adna committee
for the record I'm state senator Cindy
Rosenwald from District 13 in nashwa and
I'm happy to be here this morning to
introduce part two of this bill which
repeals the Emergency Medical Services
Personnel lure interstate compact known
as
replica this was enacted several years
ago in New Hampshire but has never been
used and in fact the nearest state that
has adopted the compact is at least 500
miles away the compact would not enhance
Public Safety because here in New
Hampshire we already conformed to
licensing and certification regulations
from other distant
States uh this this um action was
included in Senate Bill
540 of last year it um at the time
passed the Senate on a Voice vote and
then we included it in an Omnibus Bill
that unfortunately was veto
for other reasons I hope this committee
will recommend it ought to pass as an
idea that we tried but we weren't able
chair okay thank you are there questions
Roy thank you uh Madam chair thank you
senator for taking my question question
um you said that we enacted this several
years ago but isn't it true that it was
just last year during the middle of the
pandemic that it actually uh got going
because of the necessary committee
Staffing
Etc I'm sorry I I wasn't able to hear
this part of your question after but
wasn't it also
[Music]
true isn't it also true um that you said
the committee or this was enacted
several years ago but isn't it true that
it really wasn't operating until last
year during the middle of the pandemic
due to it had to be staffed
Etc I'm not aware of the Staffing thank
you for the question but um my
understanding is that it requires a
number of states to enact
it before it can become um
enforced um I believe there are other
people who can testified to the details
of
it okay I'll sa that thank
you thank you uh other questions for the
senator seeing none thank you thank you
madam
Arnold
good morning Madam chair and honorable
committee members the Department of
Defense appreciates the opportunity to
opine on the policy changes reflected in
part two of Senate Bill 133 my name is
Christopher Arnold I am the Northeast
region liaison at the Department of
Defense State liaison Office operating
under the direction of the under
secretary of defense for personnel and
Readiness uh first we would like to
discuss part two of this bill which the
department has deemed to negatively
impact our lare efforts for military
service members and their spouses to
date 22 states have adopted replica
legislation making the over 5600
licensed EMS workers in New Hampshire
eligible to practice in these States
including many who are military spouses
presently residing in other states that
would lose their eligibility continue to
to continue working where this bill to
pass in 2018 the secretaries of the Army
Navy and Air Force issued a policy
memoranda to the National Governor
Association noting they will quote
consider consider the quality of schools
near bases and whether reciprocity of
professional licenses is available for
military families when evaluating future
basing or Mission Alternatives these
considerations were codified by Congress
in the 2020 ndaa which requires the
department to produce annual scorecards
at the installation level considering
military family Readiness issues
including Interstate portability of lure
credentials in a prior scorecard in 2019
the department of the Air Force's
strategic basing off office evaluated
New Hampshire as green for EMS lure
following the 2018 passage of replica
the Air Force's approved criteria gauges
State's policies for accepting
professional licenses for EMS as part of
its strategic basing process future Air
Force basing decisions made with a
consistent framework will ensure optimal
conditions for service members and their
families this evaluation was mirrored by
dod's assessment in the 2020 letter to
Governor cunu accompanying the SE de's
report on spouse license
which assessed the granite state as
green for licensing compacts the
department perceives that part two of
Senate Bill 133 which proposes to repeal
the EMS compact negatively impacts
military spouse lure New Hampshire
already limited the scope and
implementation of replica in its
original statutory framework which
prohibits a replica Provider from
picking up regularly scheduled shifts if
passed part two of Senate Bill 133 would
make New Hampshire the first state to
ever leave a licensing compact would
which would undermine our efforts to
create licensed Reciprocity for service
members and spouses Nationwide opening
the door to other states repealing
compact under a misapprehension that New
Hampshire had left a compact for a
legitimate purpose or following serious
study it has been established that New
Hampshire is having difficulty
recruiting and retaining licensed EMS
providers in addition to the benefits to
military spouses the EMS compact
addresses this issue by making the state
more attractive to out ofate EMS
personnel as well as making it easier
for New Hampshire residents to practice
out of state and of course our military
families are well served by having the
means to move expeditiously from state
to state a 2018 study by the Federal
Trade Commission recognized there are
two approaches to alleviating barriers
to license affordability namely Mutual
recognition which relates to
occupational licensing compacts and
expedited lure occupational lure
compacts provide consistent rules for
licensed members to work in other states
simply put the EMS compact facilitates
the day-to-day movement of Ms Personnel
across the boundaries and the
performance of their duties as assigned
by an appropriate Authority without
jeopardizing Public Safety common
misinformation about compacts is that
they either lower or raise the standards
for the occupation when in fact compact
states have the option to issue a
compact license and also a state only
license to maintain their state
standards amongst the provisions compact
States utilize the National Registry of
EMTs examination as a condition of
issuing initial licenses at the em and
paramedic levels the same standard for a
military combat medic and highest in the
world the nremt standard required by
replica is in fact the competency
standard upon which New Hampshire's
certification requirements are based
compact states require EMS Personnel to
complete an FBI biometric criminal
background check when applying for a new
EMS license share licensure data
including licens disciplinary actions
with other compact States and have a
mechanism in place for receiving and
investigating complaints about indiv
indviduals which does not exist for
non-compact States EMS Personnel need to
be licensed in good standing in a home
state and practice under the supervision
of a physician qualified EMS Personnel
in compact states are extended a
privilege to practice in other compact
States on a short-term intermittent
basis the EMS compact is governed by
Commissioners appointed to the
interstate commission for EMS Personnel
practice by member states each state has
one seat on the commission and one vote
on each matter brought before the body
the best evidence we have about the
quality benefits of lure involves
occupations that have more harmonized
standards across States thus there are
very clear quality benefits to
healthcare lure regimes governed by
interstate compacts the department does
not have any strong evidence to suggest
that the type of license recognition and
replica is associated with worse quality
or Worse care outcomes as the Obama
Administration 2015 report from the
Council of economic advisers observed
quote well-designed lure can enhance
safety when consumers or patients would
find it difficult to personally assess
the quality of services they receive but
this does not provide a justification
for any conceivable licensing
restriction excessive or poorly designed
restrictions can generate a number of
costs excessive restrictions can even
impair Public Safety when they reduce
access to highquality licensed services
that is why to support our military the
department recommends stripping part two
out of this bill conversely we strongly
support and urge passage of part five of
the bill to enact the Audiology and
speech language pathology Interstate
Compact and the occupational Interstate
or the occupational therapy interstate
compact the department remains committed
to improving license portability for
military spouses the Secretary of
Defense has established military spouse
employment as a key aspect of supporting
military families and the secretaries of
the military departments have also
expressed the importance of military
spouse Lure by making it part of the
consideration for future Mission basing
the department recognizes the great work
that has already been done by your state
to support military families we hope you
continue that effort today I stand ready
to answer whatever questions you may
have thank you thank you representative
Schmidt you have a question I do Madam
chair thank you very much Mr Arnold
thank you very much for your testimony
you may be aware the past iterations of
this committee have uh worked very
carefully uh uh to try to uh remove the
kinds of uh obstructions that you're
referencing your testimony I'm wondering
my first question is whether you or
anyone from your off office offered this
testimony before the senate in its uh
negotiations and dealing with this
Bill thank you representative Schmidt
yes we did testify uh at the Senate
hearing uh and submitted testimony to
the executive departments and
administration committee as well as the
Senate finance committee uh
understanding that military spouses need
assistance now the department Advocates
that states should pursue multiple
approaches to reciprocity simultaneously
including near-term actions to attain a
baseline of getting military spouses a
license within 30 days based on minimal
documentation uh which are among the
efforts that you referenced uh that have
been previously been undertaken by this
committee as well as long-term solutions
for reciprocity through licensing
compacts and indeed New Hampshire is a
member of four Interstate licensing
compacts including replica and should
part five of this bill pass will be a
member of six uh Interstate licensing
compacts becoming one of only eight
states uh to have have joined the uh six
major Health licensing compact
Frameworks so we absolutely salute all
of your past uh efforts to support our
service members and their families
followup Madam chair followup thank you
and will you or someone from your office
be available I I believe we're going to
have sub committees to deal with some of
these issues uh would you or someone
from your office be available to assist
effort Roger uh we would be happy to do
so thank you thank you madam chair
representative
veroda thank
you so in your own words can you
um estimate the number
of people or a number of service people
this bill would removing this would
affect what would be the impact in New
Hampshire on
this Roger so there are two elements
that we're talking about one would be uh
you know persons operating in New
Hampshire uh under a compact license and
uh as uh was mentioned earlier the
compact was passed in
2018 uh and there are steps that are
taken in order to become a full-fledged
member of the compact which I believe
was completed last year so there's only
one person operating under a compact
license right now uh in the state of New
Hampshire however there are individuals
who are domiciled in New Hampshire and
involuntarily uh reside in other states
as a result of being military spouses uh
and in those compact States those
individuals could stand to lose their
eligibility uh to continue working uh
were this compact to be
repealed followup and how many people
category so the the what's known as the
defense Manpower data center does not
track Personnel in that uh fashion so it
is it is a difficult question to answer
but of the 5600 licensed EMS workers uh
uh in new hampire uh you know at least
some of them are are military
spouses
so we don't have that
information negative and there is a a
national EMS coordinated database that
is maintained uh by the compact so I'm
sure when the folks from the compact
testify uh they can answer more
specifically as to how many persons
practice under compact licenses on a
given day but in terms of tracking uh
you know home state lure out of state
that that's not
the level of the Department of defense's
involvement no
um thank
you thank you are there other
[Music]
Roy thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my
question um with regard to this light
this this bill has several aspects it's
got the dod1 and then just other people
who wish to use compact licens here with
regard to the dod portion of
it we're talking about how many New
Hampshire people are using it in other
states and how many people from other
states are using it in New Hampshire but
let's talk about
bases um so if if the dod is grading
bases on its um friendliness for a lack
of a better term to military spouses in
their ability to gain employment in the
state and all things being equal say
between Bur inton and P's Air Force Base
and base closures are are discussed as
part of that grading system would this
potentially be a reason that a decision
against PE might be
made Roger representative thank you for
the question I would refer uh everyone
to the Air Force's uh strategic basing
evaluation which is available on the uh
Department of the Air Force website and
as I indicated in my testimony the 2020
ndaa uh codified what which what was
already a voluntary practice by the
department of the Air Force to release
these annual basing scorecards in their
methodology the Air Force evaluates nine
occupations accounting cosmetology EMS
engineering law nursing Physical Therapy
psychology teaching and uh other
professions uh in as much as those are
the professions that have been
identified where the most military
spouses uh are practicing so to the
extent that in their 2019
evaluation uh pce Air National Guard
base was was green for EMS that rating
would be negatively impacted by the
133 um and I'm not sure if you're aware
or able to comment on this do you have
any idea of the economic impact to the
to the state and the area in general if
close
sorry about that I had to uh unmute
myself there so in in terms of uh you
know base realignment en closure that's
a four-letter word if you will and uh
you know I can't speculate on what the
impact of that uh might be but according
to the office of uh local defense
Community cooperation which evaluates uh
defense spending uh on an annual basis
uh the economic value of peace is
approximately 3.1 billion dollars which
is three and a half% of the state's
gross domestic product uh and ranks 14th
overall in the United States and it
supports a total of
6,337 uh personnel and all states are
bound by the or excuse me all services
are bound by the requirement in the 2020
ndaa to release the basing scorecard so
it would also apply uh to the cold lab
uh up north an addition uh uh to the air
you are there other
questions representative Schmidt do you
have another brief
question yes I do Madam chair thank you
so Min Arnold uh is is there technically
uh P the ports Naval Shipyard is um
considered in by this as part of state
of
May but it impacts this state as well uh
office any impact with regard to
portsman Naval
Shipyard Roger so uh there was a bit of
uh uh Zoom underwater there
representative Schmidt my apologies but
I did hear reference uh to to the Navy
Yard uh in as much as uh uh we're
talking about the annual basing
evaluation uh we do also have you know
an evaluation for the state of Maine
which is also in my region uh and it is
considered you know part of the the city
of Ky if you will but I I believe um you
know in as much as there are Personnel
likely living in in straford or
Rockingham uh uh you know we we we look
at both States holistically to support
the service members who are assigned
you other
will good morning Madame chair and
members of the committee my name is
Brian will and I serve as the president
of the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire representing 2,000 active and
retired firefighters and paramedics
throughout the granite state today I'm
providing testimony and support of
Senate Bill 133 part two repealing the
Emergency Medical Services Personnel
lure interstate compact otherwise known
as
replica Senate Bill 133 in its entirety
provides a number of Occupational
licensure bills that would potentially
improve the delivery of services to the
New Hampshire
taxpayer while we see the benefit in
many of these licensure compacts not all
licens or compacts are created equal
part two of this bill will actually
repeal a compact agreement that can be
detrimental here in New Hampshire the
Emergency Medical Services Personnel
licensure interstate compact that is
currently in place creates confus fusion
in our current EMS system lowering the
quality of care delivered and has the
potential to weaken our state's
economy the current model allows out
of-state EMS Personnel to migrate into
New Hampshire on a routine basis to
provide medical care and to transport
patients to out ofate hospitals drawing
theer expanded medicaid dollars out of
state currently there are no bordering
states that participate in this compact
which means that these Services would be
be migrating in from well out of state
working in New Hampshire intermittently
not paying property taxes and creating a
loss of Revenue furthermore the replica
model allows for circumvention of the
emergency response models and mutual Aid
agreements that have been proven to be
successful throughout our state
municipalities must continue to have the
autonomy to oversee their individual
Public Safety response based on their
community's needs should the replica
model be utilized it would create
unnecessary confusion within our EMS
system that could have a negative impact
for the municipality the
provider you may hear testimony today
that replica is a valuable tool that can
provide assistance in New Hampshire
during a disaster or a pandemic when in
fact the governor already has the
ability to access this assistance under
the Emergency Management assistance
compact at the federal level you may
also hear that replica is law in 21
other states all of these states are
located in the Southern and Midwestern
areas of our country where the EMS
systems are Rural and Mutual a
Agreements are far less robust than EMS
systems in New
England currently we are navigating the
worst unplanned emergency and Global
pandemic that we've ever seen without
needing to utilize replica proving that
this is a model that we simply do not
need in our state instead we must
continue to rely on best practices and
proven methods that are effective here
in New Hampshire to deliver the best
possible quality of emergency medical
services to our citizens this bill
passed the Senate last year and
unfortunately it was vetoed in an
Omnibus Bill at the end of the year we
were pleased to see this bill pass the
Senate once again this year with
overwhelming support and we respectfully
asked this committee to do the same by
passing SB 133 part two I've submitted
written testimony and I'm happy to
answer any questions that the committee
may have thank you for your
questions representative Roy
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question could you put a
little meat on the bones for me when you
talk about
um other uh States people coming in
taking uh away Mutual Aid or or taking
people to hospitals out of state if no
bordering state is a part of this
compact can you explain how that would
how that would be
possible yes representative thank you
for your question um So currently we
have mutual Aid agreements that are
designed specifically based on the
communities in need and uh what their
needs are and these are typically put in
place by department heads uh for EMS
agencies and fire departments alike um
what this does is it evaluates what the
community's needs are and how to bring
in those resources uh when our current
resources are over taxed with no
bordering state that participates in
this compact what that means is um
Services could bring in outof State uh
individuals or Personnel from let's say
uh Alabama or Kansas or Texas or one of
the other participating states to come
in and work in New Hampshire as a
licensed EMS uh professional um and the
gentleman that testified before me well
he spoke to uh everyone having a
National Registry uh emergency medical
technicians license what they do not
have is a New Hampshire provids license
and so they are operating under their
home
States uh medical Direction and their
home States scope of practice uh and
here in New Hampshire we have a medical
control board that establishes best
practices for EMS within our state uh
and when you bring in this Personnel
from um out in the midwest or from
Southern States uh they have no idea of
how we operate our EMS system here in
New Hampshire uh the waters get muddied
uh and that there's no clarification on
what the appropriate standard of care is
Hampshire thank you for I'm not sure
that that addressed the question as far
as um coming in from out of state and
taking patients away but uh let me ask
this isn't it true that under the
compact rules that if someone from
another state is here practicing on
their license from another state they
have to comport with massachusett uh
excuse me New Hampshire New Hampshire
rules
um under the practice isn't that part of
it that whatever state you're in those
are the rules that apply not the state
you came
from so uh I don't believe that's the
case representative um the the way I
understand it is the National Registry
of emergency medical technicians uh
establishes what the guidelines are to
practice within other participating
States and uh a member operates under
thank
you representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair Mr R uh
how realistic is it uh that someone
would be brought in from um Texas or the
Midwest uh Midwest is a thousand miles
away Texas is even further away um so
what's the reality in situation you're
detailing
here um what the reality is
representative thank you for your
question uh to be honest with you I do
not know but anecdotally speaking I can
tell you that um this has been um
marketed as a product that essentially
will help in uh an unplanned emergency
or a state of emergency uh or a global
pandemic and it's something that we've
not utilized it's something that's on
the books um and again anecdotally
speaking speaking you could have
services that bring in out ofate
Personnel um to come into state for a
undetermined amount of time to help um
with their Workforce and that money does
not stay in state they're here for a
short amount of time and then they turn
around and they go home um so again
anecdotally speaking it it certainly
could happen I don't know that it's
happened yet because again this is a law
that's on the books that we just don't
use followup Madam chair so if if the uh
this we're going to have to resolve this
and the subcommittee will uh be working
on it uh will you be available uh to us
or someone from your office to help us
uh deal with this situation absolutely
sir I can send you all um my contact
information you can contact me at any
you other questions representative
Bailey thank you madam
chair you have several times referred to
an unplanned emergency which puzzles me
somewhat could you give me an example of
a planned
emergency thank you for your question
representative um to be truthful uh that
was a direct quote that I took from uh
testimony in opposition to this bill uh
from the Senate hearings um so that was
in the actual um notes from that hearing
um so while that's one of the uh terms
that is being used to oppose this bill
uh I agree with you I don't necessarily
know what that
means thank you thank you other
questions thank you Mr
romanello good
morning can you
hear no you're breaking up sorry thank
you ma'am so thank you madam
chair that's better sorry about that so
thank you for your time and allow me a
few moments to speak uh as far as the
EMS personal licensure interstate
compact removing that tool from New
Hampshire has yet uh from a tool that
New Hampshire has yet to benefit from uh
would be would be a drastic measure the
compact was declared fully operational
in March of 2020 in response to the
covid-19 p mic at this time there are 21
states participating in the compact
which is an increase of six additional
States since New Hampshire adopted it in
July of 2018 to date this compact has
not been reused within borders of New
Hampshire and thus has produced no
instances where it has been proven to
show no benefit to Grant Staters on the
contrary we have seen the compact used
by New Hampshire EMS providers and other
states most recently a fellow compact
state Colorado called for a national
assistance in battling wildfires within
its borders the state of New Hampshire
wild and firefighter team responded to
this Cry for Help as part of this team a
local fire chief was able to provide
care for her teammates as well as
residents of Colorado utilizing her
privilege to practice care with no delay
all because of the EMS compact if New
Hampshire was not participating in the
compact Chief Lund would have been would
have not been able to provide care
without delays of obtaining an emergency
ler which could have put her team at
risk if injured if injury occurred
although New Hampshire has not directly
benefited from the compact to repeal it
and subsequently take this tool out of
the Em's tool box is a step backwards
this compact extends a privilege to
practice to EMS providers only and does
not bypass the requirements of
departments and agencies wishing to
provide EMS services in our state from
being licensed as an EMS unit by the
Bureau of VMS this compact simply allows
a mechanism for for our appropriately
licensed units to have access to
additional Workforce If Ever
Needed furthermore within the originally
adopted language safeguards were placed
disallowing the use of providers under
this privilege of practice extended by
the compact as regular and usual staff
Personnel in the RSA 153 a20 section 26
or sorry 24 spells this out enclosing
the compact does not harm to does no
harm to the residents or visitors of the
State of New Hampshire
the compact enables our
5600 licensed EMS providers to be part
of a 21 State initiative that extends a
resource to one another this comes at a
time where there is a national
Recruitment and Retention problem to
Public Safety as well as what we hope to
be the curtails the largest pandemic in
history in in regards to some of the
other questions that were asked I want
to make it clear that EMS services in
the state of New Hampshire are only to
be provided by licensed EMS units and
how those licensed EMS
units provide that care is through
licensed EMS
providers so any use of the Compact and
access to additional providers would
still have to be done through a licensed
EMS service so we're increasing a
Workforce but we're not bypassing who is
I'm happy to answer any questions and
I'm also available for the
sub thank you Mr romanella would you
please before you answer questions
introduce yourself and explain who you
are representing and if you'll support
our
subcommittee certainly ma'am and and I
apologize for that um so my name is
Justin romanello I'm currently the chief
of the Bureau of Ems for the State of
New Hampshire and and again I'm
certainly available tomorrow to answer
any questions or assist in this
effort thank you are there any other
romanello seeing none thank you very
much Mr Warren
Perry thank you madam chair for the
record my name is Warren Perry I'm alone
in my office in conquered I am the
deputy agitant general for New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and veteran services I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
today and I want to Echo the comments of
Mr Chris Arnold with regard to our
opposition uh to the repeal of the
replica act uh in in principle uh the
purpose or in part the purpose uh of uh
entering into this compact was to assist
in the portability of uh licensure for
military members members of the National
Guard and reserve and their spouses as
they complete active duty tours or they
are ordered to New Hampshire or out of
New Hampshire uh on Military orders
repealing this act or this compact would
adversely impact that population uh so
uh on that on that note alone uh the
department opposes this uh opposes this
uh proposed repeal uh we would uh urge
the committee to consider very favorably
uh amending uh Senate Bill 133 to
eliminate this part too uh I won't uh I
won't uh repeat any of the comments uh
we've heard in opposition to this bill
already but I'm happy to answer any
questions and I'm happy to participate
in the subcommittee if necessary thank
you thank
you representative Schmidt thank you
madam chair Mr Perry it it has not yet
been alluded to uh directly uh but tele
medicine is an ever expanding
phenomenon uh and an aspect of Modern
Health
Services uh to what degree would that be
impacted by uh this uh this part of the
of the bill I I I I'm not an expert in
emergency medical technicians or tele
medicine I would make this assumption uh
that it would not tele medicine would
not impact this very much right because
EMTs are generally First Responders who
are generally on the scene for incidents
so you know if I make the assumption
that EMTs are responding to incidents
then they have to do that in person that
tele medicine would not be
impacted thank
questions seeing none is there anyone
else who wishes to testify on part
Starz
oh
Odell thank thank you madam chairman can
you hear me yes very good thank you for
your time and members of the committee
like to thank you for the opportunity to
speak on this I I my name is Eric
schelberg I am the President of the New
Hampshire paramedical Association and
today we are uh requesting ing the
committee to strike um strike out
removal of part two of the replica
compact um a lot of what you have heard
today um had I will not rehash on those
were points that I was going to bring up
that I would just like to touch on that
I have submitted written testimony on
behalf and I hope that you have your
group has received that that the EMS
compact is as Chief romanello stated is
a tool for New Hampshire to utilize in
the event of what was earlier called an
unplanned emergency I would consider to
be a natural disaster or crisis that are
above and beyond what would normally or
typically be seen this is a mutual Aid
tool that can be utilized to bring in
Personnel to assist with the delivery of
prehosp healthc care in the state of New
Hampshire all compact members re uh
required to be certified to the National
Registry of EMT level therefore there is
a base level of training and
understanding of prehospital medicine
there are nuances with New Hampshire's
protocols however there is a great level
and standard between all levels within
the National Registry that being said
this is a tool that can be utilized as
necessary the specifically there is no
freelancing allowed so individuals could
not just come in on day-to-day
operations or be utili or be used to
fill scheduling shortfalls this would
only be used in times of Crisis or
Mutual Aid this can generate a force
multiplication and will allow for
greater protection and service to
individuals in New Hampshire citizens of
New Hampshire in times of
emergency I also do stand ready to
answer any questions you may have and
also to assist in the committee if
you representative Shu you have a
question yes I did thank you madam chair
um Mr schelberg did the uh
current well I don't know if they're
still current but the the emergency
orders that were put out for the current
pandemic uh allow such um Interstate
I am unable to answer that question for
you ma'am that question may be better
suited to Chief romanello um as I'm not
familiar with the emergency order
specifically that if there was an
emergency order that requested out of
state
assistance thank
question while he's while he's coming
back on representative Roa you have a
question thank you um I have a question
for Mr
romanello um could you clarify if you
are a
replica so uh I'm back on this is Chief
Romano I got half of that question ma'am
only because I was coming back on to
speak
oh okay do you want to answer okay my
question is are you an an sorry an at
large member of the board of um
replica so the the answer your question
that is correct ma'am so as um as the
state director for New Hampshire and
representing New Hampshire on the the
repa uh Council uh I also was asked to
be uh represent the commission itself as
a member of the board directors as a
member at large correct thank you um and
I believe the other question uh that was
asked was um do our current emergency
protocols uh allow for um uh Mutual Aid
I believe that that's what was asked I
apologize whether an emergency order
called for Mutual Aid through the
compact so it did not um we didn't we
didn't see a need um we we were
certainly thinking about uh you know the
need if it did arise and we we could ask
uh ask for assistance but again um you
know because our the closest border
state or closest state where we would
get resources from would be Delaware um
it certainly would would prove difficult
um now that doesn't mean we you know
other states uh couldn't have assisted
but again the the emac request that the
governor can ask for through Homeland
Security would certainly satisfy that um
and we also would have to pay respect to
the the additional language in the
rulemaking section of of the of the law
that that we couldn't use it for
day-to-day staff and so um would have to
scri around that if if we were going to
attempted to need to increase Workforce
um in this pandemic or you know
hopefully it doesn't happen again but if
future thank you are there other
questions for Mr h shellberg our
was good morning thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today my
name is Chris dwaz and I'm a lifelong
New Hampshire resident I currently
reside in Hollis and I'm the regional
director of American Medical Response
New Hampshire's largest 911 provider
I've been a paramedic a nationally
registered paramedic for the last 35
years uh full disclosure I think I'm the
author of The unplanned National
Emergency uh uh verbage I I believe that
was in my testimony last time uh didn't
think it would cause a Ruckus but I uh
did say unplanned uh I oppose section
two the repeal of the Emergency Medical
Services lure compact um New Hampshire
New Hampshire's participation in the EMS
compact solved the potential problem it
created a specific and defined process
for licensed qualified EMS staff to
safely cross state borders when needed
in the performance
their duties without having to hold
multiple state licenses New Hampshire
actually participates in approximately
43 interstate compacts and replica is
similar in language and intent to all of
the other lens or compacts that New
Hampshire has chosen to participated in
when New Hampshire became the 15th state
to join replica in 2018 it was the
result of a collaborative effort of
numerous New Hampshire EMS stakeholders
including the fire service commercial
ambulance providers New Hampshire
hospitals and many of the volunteer EMS
community members were so lucky to have
in our state now that the replica
compact is fully operational there are
currently 21 member states and another
state will join on July 1st bringing
that number to 22 a couple of quick
facts about replica what it does or does
not do it does not provide anyone with a
multi-state license it does not create
automatic licensed reciprocity it does
not pertain to ambulances only licensed
personnel it does not have authority
over EMS or ambulance agency lure and it
does not supersede the state of New
Hampshire EMS laws or rules it certainly
does not allow for self-deployment and
it does not allow for routine day-to-day
operations or
response it extends a privileged
individual providers to practice in
member states under authorized
circumstances and only to qualified
vetted licensed providers for specific
purposes New Hampshire has actually used
this compact as Chief Roman Ella
mentioned when deploying local
firefighters to wildfires in Colorado it
also stands up a national coordinated
Personnel database which allows the New
Hampshire Bureau of EMS to view complete
multi-state license history of
individuals share real-time significant
investigatory information share licensed
discipline history and receive
crossborder notifications about how to
State adverse
reactions notably as Mr honold and the
other gentlemen from the dod mentioned
it creates an ex expedited licensing
process for the members of the military
and their spouses separating from active
duty as a recognized patriotic employer
of the New Hampshire Garden Reserve we
believe that this is a critical
component that brings True Value to our
employees who choose to serve this
country the International Association of
firefighters on its blog site which is
dedicated to concerns about replica
States a potential solution is to look
at states such as Indiana which has
adopted language to address the issues
that the I has I completely agree if
there are Corrections or improvements
needed to make this compact better they
should be done through an amendment
process and not by fully repealing it
starting from scratch and leaving New
Hampshire without any method to
participate when needed I thank you for
the opportunity to speak I am more than
happy to um work with any subcommittee
and offer our our views so that we can
keep this important piece of legislation
in our state thank you thank you are
there
questions is there anyone else who
two the subcommittee on this will be
next Thursday starting at 10: a
and I will be delighted to have any or
participate no one else appears to be
ready to testify so we will move on oh
excuse me Mr Odell my mistake you wish
to testify please speak hi can you hear
me okay yes okay sorry about that little
technical glitch there um thank you
madam chairman and members of the
committee um my name is Clay Odell I'm a
resident of the city of Lebanon I'm a
firefighter paramedic for the Newport
fire department and I'm also a paramedic
and a registered nurse for New London
Hospital uh full disclosure I'm a former
Chief of the New Hampshire Bureau of EMS
and also a former member of the EMS
Coordinating Board for the State of New
Hampshire I would ask the committee to
amend Senate Bill 133 to strike out
section two uh which repeals the EMS
comp Compact and I would ask why the
legislature would approve of the Ms
compact in 2018 and then repeal it in in
2021 basically multi-state compacts for
healthcare professions are a good thing
they benefit the public and they benefit
the providers themselves as a registered
nurse I benefit from the uh multi-state
licensing compact uh that New Hampshire
benefits from um and it's a good thing
for for my professional colleagues uh as
nurses um as well as the public who
makes a uh uh a good use of travel
nurses and things like that in in these
days um so I guess is the is the EMS
compact flawed well my understanding of
the compact is no it is not flawed uh
the language of RSA 153a and the
administrative rules as well as the
rules of the EMS compact governing board
protect the public I have to say that
the driving force behind the repeal
effort is the International Association
of firefighters which is an organization
I have high regards for uh although I am
not a member of that
organization now the iff has determined
that a multi-state compact may be
harmful to its members they're doing
their job they're advocating for their
personnel I completely understand that
the iaff position is to oppose adoption
of the compact in states that are
considering it and to repeal it in
states where it currently
exists again I I respectfully disagree
with the Ia and their affiliate the
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire in this issue
I would point out that the majority of
the approximately 5600 EMS providers in
New Hampshire are not represented by the
pffnh and I would like to be a voice for
the silent majority I would ask you to
keep New Hampshire's membership in the
EMS Compact and amend Senate Bill 133 to
strike out section two otherwise I'm in
favor of this Omnibus Bill and finally I
would just like to um speak to Senator
Rosen Wall's comment about the compact
itself uh as far as a farthest distance
or the closest distance of a current
member being 500 miles a uh I'd like to
point out that the physical therapy
multi-state compact of which New
Hampshire benefits the closest uh the
closest state that is also a member of
that compact is in Virginia and they
have 21 states the same as the EMS
Compact and I'm fully supportive of the
um effort by the Audiology and Speech
Pathology and occupational therapy folks
to get on board to their organizations
um multi-state compa
the both of those uh compacts have
significantly less member States
involved with that than uh the EMS
compact at this time so thank you very
much uh thank you very much for your
time thank you representative
Schmid thank you madam chair uh Mr Odell
uh would you be available for the
subcommittee I will do my my very best
I'm I'm working on the 911 truck today
and the EMS gods have Smiled On me and
made me available uh the same thing for
tomorrow but I will I will or whatever
date that committee is I will do
everything I can to participate thank
you it's next Thursday not tomorrow oh
wait yes it's it's included in the uh
the other
subcommittee is there anyone else who
two seeing none we we'll move on to part
three and I'd like to call Senator Ward
sponsor see you're with
Ward I'm here
hello thank you madam chair members of
the committee um Ruth warts senator for
District 8 and I'm here to introduce
part three of SB
133 and has to do with the hearings of
the New Hampshire Board of
Nursing the board may add May hold
executive hearings concerning
allegations of misconduct or other
matters within the scope of this chapter
such hearings shall be public
proceedings any member of the board or
any other qualified person appointed by
the board shall have authority to
proceed at such a hearing and to issue
oats or affirmations to Witnesses and
that's the content of the part three of
chair thank you Senator are there any
questions
seeing
none is there anyone else who wishes to
three Madam chair uh can we do something
about the feedback that's come up it's
very interrupting and
annoying yes everyone who is not
speaking please mute yourself it will
help thank you
Lindsay Courtney you uh are wished to uh
testify Madam
chair yes representative Shu excuse me I
did have a question of Senator Ward oh
thank you I hadn't noticed Senator could
question thank you Senator Ward uh was
this a bill that was also introduced
last
year you know I don't remember that was
part of the co casual PE but I think
that Lind Courtney could answer that
question much better than I can thank
you thank
you director
Courtney thank you madam chair for the
record my name is Lindsay Courtney I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire office of professional Li
Insurance
certification um OPC wishes to express
its support of part three of this bill
and wishes to thank Senator Ward for
bringing this forward part three does
remove the prohibition in the current
nursing practice um Practice Act that
prevents the public member of the board
from serving as a presenting officer
over disciplinary hearings the Board of
Nursing is the only Board of our 54
boards councils and commissions within
the office that does not permit the
public member to Pride over hearings the
public the the Board of Nursing has
requested this legislation to
standardize requirements across the
agency and to permit all members of the
board to serve the state in this
capacity as Senator Ward mentioned um
any person um qualified by the board
including board members or non-board
members other than the public member at
present has the right to serve as a as a
presiding officer so in a sense any
person in the universe can can serve as
a presiding officer other than the
public member at this point the
presiding officer of disciplinary
hearing in simply controls the flow and
conduct of the hearing and rules on
evidentiary motions the presiding
officer does not have authority to make
decisions regarding disciplinary actions
on behalf of the board that Authority
always remains with the board a quorum
of the board must be present to
adjudicate cases and all board members
have the authority to ask questions of
witnesses the presenting officer simply
fa facilitates Communications much like
the chair of a committee during last
session um to answer representative
shu's uh question
we did um hear testimony regarding a
similar bill that some nurses were
concerned about a non- nurse presiding
over a hearing um I do believe that
those concerns are based on the mistaken
belief that the presiding officer has
authority over the outcome of the
proceedings as noted the presiding
officer has no more authority over the
outcome of the proceedings than other
board members oplc supports this bill as
it brings the Board of Nursing in line
with the other boards within oplc and
permits all board members appointed by
govern govern and Council to serve the
state in this capacity I'm happy to
answer any questions um that you may
have and thank you for the opportunity
to provide
questions just representative
Schmid thank you madam chair uh good
morning Lindsay uh so is it not the case
that a number of the boards not only
permit the public member to be uh the
presiding officer but in in fact that
it's a relatively common phenomenon for
experienced public members to be the
chair of the of their respective board
that's absolutely correct representative
and actually some board practice acts
mandate that um public members do
participate as uh the chair which is
also typically the presiding officer
board of psychology right now for
example has their public member who
happens to be an attorney as um the the
chair and presenting officer I believe
Real Estate Commission um has an acting
public member um the board of mental
health practice has um a a public member
as the chair and presenting officer and
I'm sure I can provide you with more
examples thank you no I'm I'm I just
wanted you to say representative
Bara thank you Miss um Courtney is there
um a history or an explanation as to why
a member of the public would not have
been allowed to participate in the past
so I think it really stems from uh the
notion that the presiding officer has
the capability of rendering decisions on
behalf of the board um and speaking with
some of the nurses specifically the
nursing association who had concerns
about this bill last year my um there
was concern that a not a person without
clinical experience would preside over
hearings my opinion is that that was
based on the premise that the presiding
officer has substantive authority over
disciplinary matters and if that were
the case I would completely agree um
that it should be somebody with a
nursing background but that's not the
case um and so um but I think that's
lied representative
Shu Madam chair good morning Miss
Courtney uh can you tell us how many
members serve on this particular board I
believe it's 13 it's a fa large board
we've got um two public members and then
a host of uh individuals with a clinical
questions see none thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
please
seeing none I will close the the hearing
on part three move on to part four and I
would call Senator
Khan
here Madame chairman I don't believe
Senator Khan is
present ah but I I wonder was Senator
Carson going to speak to all sections if
needed or how was that
I believe Senator Carson might be next
best person if she's still with us she
is in her hand is up
excellent that case Senator please uh
us I believe you're muted Senator Carson
sorry there we go thank you madam chair
um I will uh introduce this section I
have to jump off at
11:15 because I've got to introduce a
bill in children and family law but I
will come back um because I it was my
understanding that I was going to
introduce um these these different parts
and other Senators had asked me to
introduce for them um and with that
being said I will have to jump off
permanently at noon because I have uh to
be in conquered for a caucus um so that
being said um part
four was a bill that was introduced by
Senator KH um it is a request of the
Department of Education regarding a
change in the specification for serving
roles on the professional standard
boards and in his testimony he deferred
questions to representatives from the
Department of Education thank you okay
thank you very much in that case are
there representatives from the
Department of Education who wish to
so all right is there anyone who wishes
four please raise your hand if
so
five of which I am a co-sponsor so
representative
[Music]
Sherman thank you are you able to hear
jump Madam chair are you able to hear me
I'm sorry hear you go ahead okay thank
you uh Madame chair and the uh committee
uh for the record my name is Senator Tom
Sherman District 24 representing 11
towns on the Sea
Coast um part four of SP 133 adops the
Audiology and speech language pathology
Compact and the occupational therapy
lure
compact um this was at the request of
the American speech language hearing
Association and the
CSG um and um has the uh uh support of
oplc as well as the
boards um as um as we've heard in
earlier testimonies uh
most of the compacts um and I was
involved with bringing the nursing
compact to New Hampshire that was my
Prime bill when I was a State Rep uh
have been very successful and really
helpful in expanding access uh for
patients um and um this one seems to
have the broad support
and hopefully Susan Adams and others uh
will be able to answer any technical
questions you have on the compacts but
these
are this is uh allowing us to expand our
Workforce without having to expand uh
regulatory component or uh create
unnecessary speed bumps for people who
want to uh bring services to New
Hampshire so with that I'm happy to take
any
questions any
questions
repr right I can barely hear you
representative Roy um Senator Sherman
I'm seeing section six refers to active
duty military personnel or their
spouses um would that alleviate some of
the concerns about uh repealing as in
uh I am I'm not really clear maybe you
could help me with that
question
there thank you there were concerns
about um section
two which repeals uh Emergency Medical
Services Personnel licensure interstate
compact
yes um section six
of portion five I'm not sure how to how
to you mean of of this compa of part
five right uh refers to uh active duty
military personnel or their SP or their
spouses and I'm wondering if
that section refers to uh
emergency personnel
Personnel yeah I um I guess the the
answer to a broader question there has
really been no opposition to this
bill um we worked with uh we I made sure
that and I I believe the chair knows
this as well the the boards have been u
a part of the process as have the
associations um but this does does allow
the military component as well it does
cover that
so um I I I think it does answer some of
the concerns that may have been
expressed in part two of this Omnibus
Bill uh but as you are probably aware
the vast majority of the compacts in New
Hampshire are working very well and
achieving the goals that they originally
set out which is to not increase the
regulatory burden on providers who
already are fully licensed and um
regulated by another state that
participates in the compact agreement so
I guess one answer would be um not all
compacts are the same and I think the
EMS compact is a separate issue but this
this compact really did come with uh all
stakeholders involved uh in the process
and with their
support represent represent I'm sure
it's a different compact I understand
that but I'm wondering if it might
impact some of the same people if if
their professional licensure would
extend uh in these areas um perhaps some
of the uh other members some of the
folks that testified on that our next
witness is from the dod so perhaps he
could touch on that any other questions
for the
senator representative zitech
representative uh Senator Sherman this
um this is maybe not to you directly
this is more General general education
for me and that's there is no emergency
situation with involved in this part as
opposed to say part Roman two if there's
no emergency why can't we just use
regular reciprocity why is a compact
necessary that's that's a really good
question question what is so what is the
added benefit we don't have uh you know
I'm a physician I'm licensed in New
Hampshire uh I have had to have licenses
in every state that I've practiced um
and um so there is really
no reciprocity the beauty of a compact
in nursing and this one is that it
formalizes
reciprocity and where that really
becomes important I think is in ensuring
competency and also disciplinary action
because that's the role of our boards is
to make sure that as a physician I meet
the the standards of Competency and then
it also gives patients the ability to
bring complaints or hospitals or
otherwise to the Board of Medicine but
in a nursing compact for example which
we have in New
Hampshire uh you're held to the same
standards but your your license is
regulated elsewhere and and any
complaints or concerns are typically
handled where you are licensed but it's
a super
formal process
so um a reciprocity agreement I don't
know of any that actually exist in in
health care um or in uh in areas that
are regulated by state boards um because
it's hard to make them formal enough to
account for competency and uh ongoing
monitoring of
performance um and that's what a compact
does it creates a formal mechanism for
both of those to be addressed before
someone can practice in the state
whatever their profession
is but you're correct by the way this
does not have an emergency component but
uh anybody in any of these these
professions understands that New
Hampshire is challenged by Workforce
needs and so being able to bring people
and you know we're a small state with
three state borders being able to bring
people from Maine or Vermont or
Massachusetts having them doing
crossborder work is not competition it
availability so Senator this is
basically de facto uh
reciprocity with the disciplinary if
there were a disciplinary issue where
would it be
held uh it would be held uh based on um
you
know well my most of these comp compacts
you are you any discipline is uh brought
against your license so you would be
regulated by the licensing State and and
uh there will be people who will be
testifying after me who are much more
expert in specific uh this type of
compact with this specific
profession um which is you know
Audiology and speech language
pathology uh as well as occupational
therapy these so I would defer a final
answer to that uh to the people who
brought this
forward thank you Senator I think it's
actually in the bill you need to read it
more C thank you it is in the
Bill thank you Senator um the chair
recognizes Christopher Arnold from the
Defense uh thank you uh Mr Vice chairman
and uh please for the opportunity to
speak on part five uh committee members
thank you again I am Christopher Arnold
I represent the Department of Defense
and we are grateful for the opportunity
to support the policy changes uh
reflected in subp Parts a andb of part
five of Senate Bill 133 much like
replica uh none of the states bordering
New Hampshire have enacted either of
these two compacts yet regardless New
Hampshire should be among the first to
adopt these compacts Maine does have a
bill for the occupational therapist
compact pending as the first lady said a
few weeks ago
helping military families with these
issues is critical to our national
security from 2011 to 2016 the
department worked with all 50 states
through common methods used by licensing
boards to expedite the acceptance of a
license from another state many states
enacted some form of relief 39 States
enacted laws for endorsement of a
current license from another state 42
States enacted laws for temporary lure
and 31 States enacted laws for expedited
application procedures however these
methods proved insufficient to address
the underlying concerns of military
spouses further changes to lure to
facilitate reciprocity and state lure
programs for military spouses will
continue to take time to cover all
occupations in all states complicating
matters further terms such as
reciprocity and expedited are used
differently among the states the
department pivoted its approach in 2017
to consider occupational lure compacts
as another alternative to improve
portability for military spouses
compacts establish common understanding
of Competency and its measurement within
the occupation and then seek to have
States approve the compact through
legislation with this said all of these
approaches can be beneficial if they
produce a baseline result of having the
military spouse be able to receive a
license in approximately 30 days without
submitting verifying documentation
outside of verifying the standing of the
license and fulfilling a background
check DOD has assisted organizations
representing occupations with obtaining
State approval of their compacts where
these compacts have benefit to the
military these compacts cover
approximately 40% of military spouses
who need a license to work like replica
these two compacts were designed to
enhance the state's ability to protect
the Public's health and safety
especially client and patient safety
these three compacts encourage the
cooperation of compact states in the
areas of EMS Audiology and speech
language pathology and occupational
therapy lure and regulation the compacts
facilitate the exchange of information
between compact States regarding lure
adverse actions and disciplinary history
occupations are generally needed to
establish a National Database of
practitioners to operationalize the
compact portability practices for
example states in the EMS compact share
a coordinated data system that enables
them to share license history on EMS
Personnel including license denials
revocations and significant
investigatory histories this data system
is anticipated to be fully populated by
the end of 2021 and is a critical
element for states to assure they are
issuing licenses only to qualified
Personnel who have no concerning
backgrounds which I might add would
answer some of the earlier questions
regarding New Hampshire domiciled
service members and spouses who are
serving out of States once that system
comes online all three compacts promote
compliance with the laws governing
practice in each compact state finally
the compacts invests all compact states
with the authority to hold licensed
workers accountable through the Mutual
recognition of compact state license the
Department's 2017 military spouse
licensure portability examination state
report by the University of Minnesota
examined five occupations in each state
for occupational therapy the report
found that RSA 332 G sub7 requires
boards to facilitate the issuance of
licenses contingent upon the opinion of
the board as to whether a spouse's
previous requirements of lure are
substantially equivalent but for occup
ational therapy that certain spouses
must apply for new lure uh as though
they are a new applicant and that those
who do hold active licenses in other
states must submit verification of their
previous licenses a time-consuming
process that can take months the
department Advocates that to achieve
immediately attainable actions near-term
actions and long-term solutions they be
pursued simultaneously to gain as much
flexibility for military spouses in the
near term while preparing for
substantially improved portability in
the future as a result the department
anticipates the cumulative impact of
these processes should represent a more
significant impact for example if
processes that Implement statutory
changes for military spouse lure are in
place they will greatly enhance the
impact of further changes to policies
that allow military spouses to obtain a
license in 30 days without submitting
verifying documents likewise while these
initiatives get military spouses to work
more quickly compacts can provide
seamless Reciprocity for military
spouses in an occupation EMTs
occupational therapists audiologists and
speech pathologists can move from a
compact state to another compact state
without any relicensing when they move
to or from a non-compact state then
having the 30-day without submitting
verification approach can help get them
to work faster consequently engaging in
state only licensure reform
simultaneously with improving Interstate
relationships through compacts provides
for Optimum access by military spouses
we appreciate the opportunity to support
the policies outlined in the audiology
and speech language pathology Interstate
Compact and the occupational therapy
compact introduced this session and
thank Senator Sherman for his leadership
and his sponsorship joining these
compacts will allow military personnel
and spouses to more easily maintain
their certifications when relocating
please feel free to uh address whatever
questions you may have thank
you representative
Shu thank you Mr chair um thank you um
sir I you probably heard my previous
question
uh about whether
this of the compact would alleviate some
concerns for military uh personnel and
their spouses reason for my uh thinking
this is my particular
town uh has uh EMS services but most of
the employees there are part-time and I
know of two of them in fact who work
full-time as physical therapists so my
thinking was that if you are involved in
the medical professions you might tend
to have those overlying capabilities do
you know if uh any of the uh people who
would be involved in EMS Services would
also be physical therapists or apply
under this
compact so to the extent uh that a
person may hold one or more professional
licenses certainly if they are uh a
physical therapist uh relocating from
one compact state to another compact
state uh that compact is of benefit to
them however if they are also a
paramedic or an EMT uh and they are
relocating from a compact state to a
non-compact state uh New Hampshire's
leaving that compact would be highly
detrimental uh to that individual uh I
might add it would also uh to to speak
the question about disciplinary uh
actions be detrimental to the state in
that repealing replica uh would mean the
granite state gives up its ability to
suspend or revoke an outof State EMS
person's privilege to practice in New
Hampshire uh under that provision of the
EMS compact New Hampshire has full
control over its ability to suspend or
revoke the privilege to practice of an
outof State person functioning in New
Hampshire under the compact's privileged
to practice uh if New Hampshire or any
other State revokes a person's privilege
to practice that person loses that same
privilege in all other compact States in
addition the home state that issued the
person's license would agree to
investigate whatever infraction led to
the revocation of the privilege to
practice as if it happened in the Home
State uh accordingly a person could lose
their home state license based on
something they did out of state and
similar protections are in place for
both the occupational therapy Compact
and the Audiology and speech language
pathology compact contained in part
goalie thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Arnold Tak my
question did I I understand correctly in
your testimony uh in the beginning that
the uh Department of Defense was uh
specifically looked at compact in
starting compacts uh to alleviate um
issues with uh mil Personnel who have
been moved or looking to go to um uh be
removed from
service Roger so that that is correct
and if you go back to uh the
2019 National Defense authorization act
there was in fact a requirement for the
secretary to enter into a Cooperative
agreement with the Council of state
governments and their Center for
interstate compacts for the development
of new uh Interstate occupational lure
Compact and uh in fact three weeks ago
uh there was a press release from the
secretary uh because there had been $5
million to facilitate that process
announcing uh five new occupations that
had been selected to develop interstate
compacts including teachers dentists and
dental
hygienists massage
therapists uh
cosmetologists so as you can see uh this
has been sort of identified on our
Continuum as the uh Optimum means for
pursuing reciprocity that being said uh
there is not a compact for every
occupation uh nor is every state a
member of each compact which is why we
advocate for a variety of solutions
simultaneously thank you follow up yes
go ahead follow
up would you be supportive of compacts
being specifically for military
personnel and spouses versus opening up
to
everyone Roger so to to the extent uh uh
that the work goes into drafting a
compact it brings together uh
stakeholders from the occupation uh and
the qualifications in the compact are
defined by an Advisory Group and a
drafting team composed of State policy
makers
practitioners state board members uh to
develop a balanced set of standards for
portability that would apply to uh all
practitioners so in terms of of getting
that team together uh for drafting uh to
focus on protecting Public Safety of
consumers uh and appealing to the vast
majority of states in order to be
positively uh considered uh uh we would
we would support the approach that uh uh
followup follow
up so that being said it obviously would
be the Professionals of the board that
would be setting the standards for the
compact would you be in favor of the
compact solely being in place for those
military individuals that we've talked
about Department of Defense is looking
to
cover I'm sorry so I'm not sure if
you're if you're referring to
uh a compact that only applies to
military personnel but we're talking not
only about active duty uh uh service
members but also uh their spouses
recently uh separated veterans uh
reservists and and and guards person as
well that is correct and that's what I'm
talking about covering all those
individuals Roger and and compacts do uh
which is why found them to be an optimal
approach thank you thank you any further
Arnolds seeing none I will recognize
up uh yes I just wanted to address
representative scc's question um I had
to uh go back and into the bill and the
way to think about this uh first of all
um to think about this is that there is
basically a home state and where the
person is actually practicing or
providing services and so in the state
in which the person is providing
Services that's while the person is
providing Services they are subject to
all and the way the bill reads the state
laws do process um and all of the uh
activity of the state's regulatory
Authority
so um and the action that that state may
take if there is a a disciplinary
concern is to revoke their um compact
privilege in that state uh and then they
also notify the home state so just to
clarify the home state holds the license
and could use action by another State's
board um if they wanted to and to
encumber the
license um and when a license is
adequately encumbered or um you know
there's concerns the person can lose
their compact privileges in other states
until that license is cleared so I hope
that answers representative scc's
question where the disciplinary process
lies so that's that's really good news
for New Hampshire because if you have
somebody from a compact state uh then
that person is practicing in New
Hampshire and they are subject to the
boards in New Hampshire for their
compact privileges those boards cannot
impact directly that person's license
which is held in the home state but this
has worked very well and just um briefly
addressing representative gool's
concerns these are all state boards they
are non-military boards um that oversee
this I would think it would be you know
the goal here is to
to um allow people to
practice uh in multiple States whether
they military or
not without having to be encumbered by
multiple licenses and it has been
incredibly effective in the nursing
boards and many of the compact
Arrangements that we already have but it
would be I would think it would be very
difficult to do this for just for
military because the boards are civilian
boards that oversee all of these
licenses um and I would urge you to uh
approve this section section five um so
that it can move forward and allow for
um really an an increasing the reservoir
of people who are available U to work in
the state of New Hampshire I'm
sure thank you
sh anyone else wishing to testify on
this
scill Mr chair yes go hand up I'm sorry
my my computer actually died so I'm
we're sharing one
with go go ahead
uh just a quick uh question uh Senator
Kelly
can you hear me yes go ahead good
morning Madam chair and members of the
committee I'm Tina Kelly appearing on
behalf of the office of professional lur
and certification support of five part
five the Audiology and speech language
pathology Compact and the occupational
licensing
compact an individual who holds a
license in a member state will be issued
a privilege to practice in this state
um these individuals holding a privilege
to practice are required to follow the
scope of practice of the State of New
Hampshire where the patient a client is
located in addition holding the
privilege to practice will subject to
all laws and rules of the state where
the patient or is located and can if
necessary suspend that privilege to
practice in the state of New
Hampshire these compacts will allow ease
of Mobility between between states while
keeping all safeguards in place this
includes all types of military anybody
who has the appropriate
training this will ensure a standard
requirements for lure across compact
state those requirements include things
like education
examination verification of states where
the person has worked background checks
a person licensed in a compact state who
wishes to practice in another compact
state will not re be required to
resubmit these documents in each state
reducing the time and cost to that
person these compacts will ensure boards
retain all authority they currently have
over their PR over those practicing in
the state of New Hampshire whether or
not the practi practitioner is
practicing here under a Hampshire issued
license or a
compact these compacts will allow
cooperation and communication across
state lines with regards to
investigations in conclusion the passage
of this portion of Senate Bill
133 will allows will allow for ease of
Mobility ensure standard standardized
licensing requirements and the ability
to investigate and take disciplinary
actions against the privilege to
practice when
necessary when putting this
um compact forward we cannot change the
language of this compact because then we
would not fit in with what the other
states do and it just it wouldn't work
to tweak the language of the compact to
change it to just one type of person or
somebody who might be in the military or
somebody who's not this is designed to
benefit all individuals who are
occupational therapist occupational
therapy assistants speech language
pathologist audiologist anyone in in
those
professions so with that said I'd be
glad to take any questions you might
Maguire thank you Miss Kelly is
it essentially the case that by joining
a compact the board is is deciding that
the comp the requirements for lure
required by the compact states are
equivalent to those of new
Hampshire that is correct when a state
adopts or um passes legislation to
become part of the compact they're
accepting Baseline requirements that
would be a standardized education a
standardized exam so that every state
going into the compact has the
same um requirements to become licensed
and all the states are agreeing that
that is where the initial um requirement
should be for entry into the
profession thank you representative
fellows thank you um my question
is the compact except for military
personnel a person who moves from
another state and is initially certified
based on their home state license once
they once they moved to New Hampshire
and they're a resident here when it's
time for renewal of
their what was their home state they
have to renew in New Hampshire can you
tell me the length of um the license how
how often do audiologists and speech
pathologists have to renew in other
states and also in New
Hampshire okay so states are different
with where with their renewal but let me
start at the beginning of
that um what happens is is you have your
home state you have your license there
you get your privileges to practice in
other states if you leave that home
state you have to wherever you're living
and whatever is your state you reside in
you have to have a license there in
order to have those privileges to
practice so if you leave that home state
you have to get another priv uh license
and then re obtain your privilege to
practice because you the compact doesn't
know whether you'll move to a state that
isn't part of the compact or is part of
the compact so once you get that license
in your state and you're the home state
and you're going to renew you would
renew based on theirs no matter what the
other states do so in New Hampshire it's
every two years so if the person is here
and licensed here and getting privileges
to practice from here they would still
renew every two years in their New
Hampshire cycle
thank
you any other questions from Miss
Kelly yes representative
lakas um thank you uh Mr Vice chair what
I'm wondering is uh how do the compact
requirements for the various licenses
compared to the existing ones uh in New
Hampshire I mean are ours have do ours
have less requirements more
requirements how do they compare
our requirements currently line up
exactly with the requirements that are
in this
compact right thank
you representative scitech so I'm kind
of Johnny one note here except for what
I heard earlier about people coming in
on a freelance basis for occasional work
with that exception this is super
streamlined reciprocity is it not yes
it's reciprocity while still uring one
of the big components of having a
compact is the ability that if somebody
has a privilege to he practice here and
they have a license in their home state
and they were to do something here we
could remove that privilege to practice
but we can also work with the other
state or States if they have more than
one privilege to practice in any type of
Pearson thank you Mr
chairman ma'am it's uh so if I'm
understanding you
correctly in in in what you said about
the changes and and how language cannot
be tweaked if the state of New Hampshire
had something a circumstance that was
unique or some sort of um or some sort
of situation where where the folks in
New Hampshire thought this the standard
should be
a little bit more stringent or there was
a or was a specific item to New
Hampshire that we wanted to put in to
those protocols would then we now be
restricted because because we are part
of this multi-state compact from being
able to do
so okay so once we if this legislation
went through and New Hampshire decided
that there was something that needed to
be tweaked with the compact there's the
compact Commission and New Hampshire has
a seat on that
commission and um you would take the pro
the concerns there you would discuss it
and as a group the group would decide
whether or not that would be something
that needed to be changed if New
Hamshire felt strongly enough that you
know whatever it was was not protecting
our citizens we'd have to go back and
repeal the Compact and
um but so your short your short answer
is no we would not be able to do that
that's that's correct but one of the
things on getting in on the ground floor
of these compacts when they're in their
formation stage New Hampshire would have
a seat at that table in forming the
compact
groa
represent G you're
muted thank you Miss Kelly we do have
reciprocity with other
states with with other professions and
we have
compacts as well with other states we're
part of compacts is that correct that is
correct and why would we choose one over
the
other as far as reciprocity or a compact
correct so it's very difficult with
reciprocity to determine um sometimes
whether or not some standards rise to
the same standards as in New Hampshire
and it's very timec consuming to go
through every state to make that
determination and then even though
you've made that determination a state
can just change something which may take
them out of alignment with what New
Hampshire does with a compact you're all
in agreement you're dra in it together
so you don't have to worry that
tomorrow um another state will change
their requirements and possibly have
somebody who's not qualified come into
the state in
practice follow up follow up thank you
how is um so this discussion on comp who
supervises how um people who are coming
into the state under to this compact are
actually
um Let me let me rephrase that could I
rephrase the question um does this
compact therefore replace the function
of
oplc or the boards how is that how does
that how does the function of the
Compact and the regulations within the
compact
um affect how op PLC Works in you know
during its standard
day it it it would not affect what the
board or oplc can do at all what the
compacts at a higher level it's
basically the licensing requirements the
licensing of a person not scope of
practice within the state that the
patient or client is located not the RO
laws and the rules of the State of New
Hampshire if somebody's here practicing
on a patient client located within the
state of New Hampshire they have to
follow all of our laws and rules as they
stand right now the only difference is
that they're coming and they're getting
a quicker license to come in and
practice um one of the things that it
does regulate is if we were to take away
the privilege to practice or another
state were to take away a privilege to
practice they lose all their privileges
to practice um until it's resolved so
there's that safeguard that somebody
won't lose it in one state and still be
practicing here
unsafely um okay and could I have one
last question Mr chair yes of course um
how do we know that this person has lost
their license in another state how is
that communicated to us the com and I
can speak to what I've seen I was
involved in the PT Compact and these
these two are basically the same the PT
compact has been working very well and
when somebody gets dis disciplined or
something happens in another state that
compact commission notifies the state of
New Hampshire notifies the board um with
um written communication that something
has
happened thank you you're
gold thank you Mr chair thank you Miss
Kelly for taking my
question um I heard this uh
similar response when we were looking to
on the replica build
um I hear you say that we need to do
this so we can have a seat at the
table can you tell me how many people
are at that table when we get a seat at
it that I'm not sure there is there is a
threshold that has to be met in order
for the compact to be
formed and I want to say 15 but I'm not
sure it's right in the compact language
itself I'd have to look it up but once
that is met then the com the the compact
states with a representative from each
state come together and they set the
rules of how the compact will be um how
it will work um like you know the
database will work when notifications of
discipline are sent out all of those
things it sets those proced ures so that
they're formulated right in language and
it's always good to have a seat at the
table when those things are initially
being formed that way if you come into
the compact later around down the road
they're already formed and you have to
go through a different process to get
anything
changed does that follow up follow
up so my my question
is if we're one of say 15 and even
though now that we're in this uh we
don't agree to Something in those
procedures we have to go through the
whole process of what we're looking at
on repealing replica to get out
correct that would be correct but I will
say that like I said before the PT
compact was enacted I'm thinking four or
five years ago we got a seat at that
table when that was being
formulated it's basically the same type
of compact and I can tell you right now
the PT compact works
wonderfully um it's been very beneficial
the people on that um compact
commission um they work very closely
work together and their goal is
public followup
followup
and just because we have the initial
seat at the table doesn't guarantee us a
seat at the table forever on that board
I would imagine that it would rotate
through that would be every every state
who's part of the commission has a seat
at the table when they come on they
automatically get a seat it would be the
officers that may be rotated there may
be five or six officers you know a a
chair a vice chair I'm not sure how it's
going to be but it would be that similar
structure just just like a board would
work and one last
followup last followup
so as the numbers increase or the makeup
of the seats at the table change the um
initial seat at the table that we had in
making these rules obviously could
change and may not to be completely to
our liking we may not agree to
everything that is in there further on
down the road correct that could happen
but we get a vote on whatever changes
would be made we always have a vote we
always have a say and
so yeah it may not be to our liking but
the core requirements for
lure and the core um outline of what it
is going to look like to be part of that
compact is in legislation so I don't
anticipate there there would be anything
that could be put forth that would be so
detrimental that the board or the state
of New Hampshire would see that as
something that would
um push them forward to get out of the
you thank you um I'd like to just ask a
a question for myself if I may
if let's say that during the an annual
meeting a proposal is made that New
Hampshire does not agree with can you
could you explain the process how that
would work and
um and
how we could avoid
that so if we didn't agree with with
something that was being put forward it
would be just like on a board you would
discuss it you with all the other
members with a representative from each
other each other state all the members
and it would be majority
vote um but like I said I don't see
because the core and the basics that
really structure this are in this law I
don't anticipate there would be anything
that would come out of this that would
be so detrimental the board would feel
that it was necessary to get
out thank
you representative L
Lake thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um this may have
been answered already but um there's a
lot to digest in this so I'm going to
ask again in case it
hasn't suppose something came up uh
there was a change in the board meeting
um I mean I'm sorry at at the board
meeting that New Hampshire found to be
an irreconcilable difference is there a
penalty for any um compact
member to just throw up their hands and
get
out well if we were to get out of the
compact if we were to repeal this
legislation once it's enacted then
anybody who had a privilege to practice
would lose that privilege to practice
and they would have to go and get
licenses from each state that they wish
to hold a license in well so then in
other words we would just be back to
where we were without the compact it's
it's uh other than that there's no
detriment to just throwing up our hands
and leaving if we found it necessary
correct thank you representative scitec
U I'm getting the analogy here that the
compact is really a super
oplc you don't have anything to do the
compact will have nothing to do with the
scope of practice which is the thing
that would concern me most right that's
correct if when somebody's practicing in
this state they have to follow all the
laws and rules and that would be
everything that's currently on the books
they have to follow everything and the
Gro thank you Mr chair um Miss Kelly if
we wanted to know which um
compacts and which
um reciprocity agreements we have in
place where would we find that
information we could get that from
oplc would you be able to provide that
to us please y thank
you representative
Pearson thank you Mr chair my inquiry
involves uh liability and
insurance currently depending on your
profession and whether or not you're a
government employee there are certain
insurance policies for various things
negligence and and um malpractice and
whatnot now with this compact that
you're talking about these folks are
going to I would is it fair to presume
they're not going to be covered by their
insurance automatically in other states
are you know are we looking at a
situation where folks if they decide to
to be involved at this level
they would have to expand the the
insurance that they carry to cover them
practicing outside of their home state I
I do not have any idea I would imagine
that they would have to because all
insurance companies are different and
coverage is different they to contact
their insurance company to see what it
exactly covered and what they would have
to
do thank you Miss Kelly I'd like to ask
a question with regards to the insurance
that just piqued my interest
does New Hampshire currently cover
require insurance for this profession
and as part of the compact people would
have to um comport themselves to the
Hampshire requirements they would by
necessity have to obtain insurance is
that
correct from what I understand from the
board's administrative rules there is no
requirement in those administrative
rules that dictates what insurance
but if New Hampshire requires Insurance
in to practice in our state you have to
follow the rules of the state you're in
would that not mean then that you would
need to have insurance that is correct
thank
you representative brto
followup you have another question oh
I'm so sorry I forgot to lower my hand
apologies okay representative scitech
um you'll see where I'm going with this
question have we had any bad experiences
compacts I can't ex I can't speak to all
the other compacts the one compact that
I've been involved with is the physical
therapy governing board's
compact um and from everything I've
known and I was in that from its
Inception involved in that I have not
seen anything that we ran
into that was any kind of an issue at
all there might have been one thing at
the very beginning with um lenses and it
was to do with insurance but I think it
was um Medicare or Medicaid and that was
all worked out I have no idea what it
was but I know there was a little glitch
the compact commission worked on it it
was all resolved so I'm and once those
get resolved they carry through to other
understanding thank you any further
Kelly seeing none thank you Miss Kelly
Adams thank you Mr Vice chair and
members of the committee my name is
Susan Adams and I'm the director of
State Legislative and Regulatory Affairs
for the American speech language hearing
Association and I'm here to ask for your
support of Senate Bill 133 Section 5 the
Audiology and speech language Prof ol
ology interstate contact Asha um began
this project with the Council of state
governments in 2017 to develop an
interstate licensing compact for our
members at that time we met with a
number of state legislators State
Licensing boards State associations and
other stakeholders holding hundreds of
phone calls and webinars to discuss the
Compact and how it could work um as
you've heard from Mr Arnold we work
specifically with the Department of
Defense on language related to Military
and Military
spouses the ASL pic is designed to allow
audiologists and speech language
Pathologists to practice across state
boundaries through
telepractice um and in person both
legally and ethically without
necessitating an individual become
licensed in every state and it increases
consumer protection by expanding the
prosecutorial net for Bad actors it's
very similar in Form and Function to the
current occupational lens or compacts
for medicine nursing psychology and
physical therapy
we now have 10 states that have passed
the legislation which is the threshold
for the compact commission to begin
operations um those 10 initial member
states are Alabama Kansas Kentucky
Louisiana Oklahoma Nebraska North
Carolina Utah West Virginia and Wyoming
in addition Georgia and Maryland have
passed their legislation and it's
awaiting signatures by their
Governors um given that we have the 10
states that can begin operations we
don't expect a commission meeting to be
to be held until probably the fall so
any states that pass uh the the
legislation between now and then would
also have a seat at that initial um
meeting and that's the meeting where the
rules and the bylaws for the compact um
will be developed so those states that
are sitting at that table will have
probably the most influence on what goes
into those rules and bylaws it's
unlikely that those rules and bylaws
will change much if at all um once
they're developed by the states and
other states are expected to take those
rules and bylaws in addition to the
compact language
in uh and and be able to follow those um
once they join the compact at a later
date um so I hope we can count on your
support to move this bill forward so
that we can increase care for the
residents of new New Hampshire with
communication disorders and I'm happy to
answer any questions you may have and
can be available to the subcommittee if
needed
any questions for Miss
Adams representa do you have any sense
thank you do you have any sense of why
Pennsylvania New York Vermont
Massachusetts places a little closer to
us have not gotten into this why are we
the uh the uh guinea pigs of the East
Coast um thank you for your question
representative uh there States really
have a a variety of reasons as to they
haven't joined the compact uh
Massachusetts for example has a an issue
that they're working on that's very
important to them and that's lure for
clinical fellows they're the only state
in the country that doesn't license uh
speech language pathology clinical
fellows so they really want that
legislation to pass because they've been
working on it for so long before they
take up a new um a new issue so to speak
um Pennsylvania is interested we are
hoping that we'll get a bill introduced
there next year um New York for example
just doesn't generally like compacts and
they're one of those states that hasn't
joined any compact so they're probably
not going to be the front runner they're
going to be the probably the last state
to join so this is only our second year
in state
legislatures um and you know we
certainly are working for this to become
a 50 state compact so we will you know
keep approaching those states in the
also any further questions from Miss
[Music]
Adams there being none thank you Miss
Adams anyone else wishing to testify on
Section Five of s SP 133 please raise
your
hand there being none I'm going to close
the hearing on Section Five and return
the gaple back to Chairman
WI
yes thank you I actually was an error
I'm not a co-sponsor part
five part seven so it being uh afternoon
we will break for lunch we will resume
at
1:30 picking up with Section six which
is the music
therapist right take a break and we'll
now
better straping fortified with coffee
this
time
out I'm gonna have to look back at the
my two two Big Blocks miles
yeah
wasn't very hurt that I wasn't given
100%
don't you get a
98.5
everyone Senate Bill
133 Miss smling were you able to get in
avart uh Senator avard was actually here
all morning and he did not come back so
um I can give him a call right now I
thought he would return okay if not we
right
in that case representative McGee if you
would care to introduce this section of
the bill since you're a co-sponsor
yes oh go ahe please remember that we
have heard your bill on music therapists
and we heard all the testimony so you
don't need to
repeat I would hope it would be this
should be a fairly brief section thank
you yes thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you members of Edna I'm
representative C McGee of Hillsboro 27
Hollis and I'm here today uh
representing my constituent who is a
board-certified music therapist Shannon
Lane who is the current director of
music therapy and adaptive lessons in
early childhood at the Manchester
Community Music School um she was the
first person to bring me uh this issue
and I had submitted a bill to this
Committee in the last session which um
was one of the
predicating reasons for the bill that's
before you today so I only bring that
history up because that bill was heard
by this committee in January of 2020 and
then there was a subsequent subcommittee
and the language resulting from uh the
four meetings of that subcommittee uh
evolved into the language that is before
you on pages 38 to 41 of SB 133 which is
section six and that is the uh lure and
regulation of music therapy so um let's
see the committee's quite familiar with
the bill as the chairwoman are already
mentioned um and
um and the content so I'm not planning
to go over anything about oursa 328 F on
Allied health professionals and I
believe um Marissa Scott is here to
answer any questions about the
profession for herself or colleagues I
can just say that as I've grown um in
being a member of the house I've learned
about the process of lawmaking and I
believe that one of the most inspiring
aspects of our work is really to watch
people step up and let their
representatives know what it is that
they need from us and then teaching us
what we don't know I've learned a great
deal about music therapy and about the
caring professionals who use this form
of therapy to transform their clients
lives with tailored plans and and
quantifiable goals um and I just uh
relate this to I broke my wrist in 2018
and I ended up working with a pair of
hand therapists at Apple Therapy in
nashwa um I started out with little to
no mobility and strength was not even on
the menu so I have some understanding
for what it means to have a significant
disability that needs to be tended to by
someone who actually understands how to
nurture you through the process and that
is how I relate to what I have learned
about um these certified music
therapists um so just imagine how a
board certified music therapist is
uniquely qualified to do that type of
therapy meeting with a meeting a client
with neurological or developmental
limitations where they are and then
gradually moving them towards greater
functionality um it's Noble and unique
work and these talented patient
professionals want to be legitimized for
the education that they Undertake and
the caring that they display and doing
meaningful work for the clients they
serve this is not a therapy that
detracts from other forms of therapy
it's a specific form of therapy that is
applied when it is the appropriate
choice and um just like I would not see
a back specialist when rehabbing a
broken wrist so that I could regain use
of my dominant hand um the this
particular form of therapy I think its
time has come in terms of being added to
the Allied therapies that are available
to people in New Hampshire and I'm sure
you'll hear more on that later today so
I hope that you can see your way clear
to passing section six of H of SB 133
here today to save us all from doing it
again because in case you haven't
noticed these music uh therapy folks are
very determined they're not going to
stop until um until they can find that
they have the lure and and
Regulatory um supports that they require
excuse me representative McGee are you
threatening
us well at this point I feel it there's
no harm no harm no
foul um no I am not but I I think I
think I want you to understand how much
determination the people that I have met
in this profession have shown me so I'm
sure that um they'll be back again if if
it doesn't go through this time so I
just thought I'd let you know
that and that's it I if there's anything
else I can answer for you I'd be happy
to
okay there questions from the
committee none thank
you thank you representative
McGee
is still I still don't see Senator avart
so no I have not had success contacting
him I've tried okay
um Marissa Scott I think is
the yes there she is okay we will bring
her in
and
hello hello please introduce yourself
and keep your testimony brief because
we've already heard about music therapy
earlier this year yes yes um thank you
chairwoman Maguire and thank you members
of the committee so I'm Marissa Scott
and I want to thank you for your
listening ears today I know you're very
familiar with our portion of the bill um
I'm speaking to you of course on the
behalf of the New Hampshire task force
for music therapy State recognition I'm
also a board-certified music therapist
and I'm a female business owner in the
state of New Hampshire I live in Dover
where my business where I run my
business um with my husband and my four
kids um and I I've previously come to
you before to discuss the lure of Music
therapists and specifically how it will
help constituents by increasing access
to services and um allowing constituents
to find a qualified provider um we do
have several instances right now of
people saying you know oh I do music
therapy and they have no Education and
Training so that's just really wanting
to protect the um the Education and
Training of a music therapist um and
also you know protecting the
constituents um and so since I've
already spoken uh at Great length on
this topic I would like to be mindful of
your time but I wanted you know that I
am here I'm happy to answer
questions um and I participated fully in
the Senate hearings and there was no
opposition to our section during the
Senate process thank you um I had a
question when we heard the
representative McGee's House Bill
the speech language Pathologists were
still concerned about the scope of
practice in music therapy has that been
resolved uh yeah so I think part of the
the um thank you for your question the
part of the problem was that
um the American Music Therapy
Association and the American Speech
Therapy Association are communicating
with each other at the national level
and they have agreed upon the language
that's being being put forth in the
bills that are going out in different
states and it doesn't always trickle
down to the state level in time but we
have what is in this bill the agreed
upon language between um AMTA and um and
Asha and so it's just a a matter of
communicating at the state level as well
um we're open to communicating with them
but the language in this bill was what
both agencies agreed upon
questions okay seeing
Adams
raised pardon us we're we're having a
little technical difficulty in training
has Madam chair can you hear me now yes
thank you sorry about the delay thank
you madam chair members of the committee
my name is Susan Adams and I'm the
director of State Legislative and
Regulatory Affairs for the American
speech language hearing Association and
I'm actually here to ask for amendments
to this bill because the language that
has been presented is not a language
that has been agreed upon by all the
parties involved and in fact there is no
language that uh AMTA and Asha have
agreed upon so the language presented to
you as as being um agreed upon by all
parties is is not true um
Asha doesn't oppose the ler and
regulation of Music therapists but we
are concerned about infringement of
scope of practice for speech language
Pathologists um although a music
therapist can and does treat individuals
with communication disorders um they're
not qualified to to treat the
communication disorder itself which
Falls solely under the scope of practice
of
slps slps are uniquely educated and
trained to assess treat and uh assess
and treat speech language swallowing
cognitive medication disorders in
children and adults these Services help
children acquire language and enable
people to recover essential skills to
communicate about their health and
safety to swallow adequate nutrition
safely and to have sufficient attention
memory and organizational skills to
function in their environment we have
worked with uh music therapists and
other states to clarify this language so
that it's clear that although they can
contat can treat a uh individual with a
communication disorder that work is is
related to
um communication skills and not treating
the communication disorder itself I hope
we can uh share language so that New
Hampshire can include this also to
ensure that there is no confusion as to
which uh professionals provide which
Services I'm happy to answer any
questions and be available to the
subcommittee thank you very much are
there
one representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair good
afternoon Miss Adams uh so uh I'm
wondering whether the language that you
are uh asking us to consider uh was
offered to the senate in the course of
the development of the
Bill thank you representative Schmidt it
has not been offered in the Senate yet
because the language was just agreed to
um in Maryland in the last couple of
weeks so it was uh it occurred after the
the Senate uh
hearings followup followup
when you say agreed to you mean that you
and the music therapist organization
your organization and theirs agreed to
it uh that language in the state of
Maryland yes thank
broa thank you Madame
chair um I guess this question could go
to either representative McGee or
Miss Scott we had a subcommittee last
year on this bill and we met and there
was a woman um I believe her name was
Miss chesterly who was a part of that
subcommittee work and we had come to an
agreement regarding an amendment on this
bill so I wanted to know is this
language that so I'm not sure if Miss
Adams is is up to date on that so is
this language
that is being
that yes Scott you can you answer that
question yes thank you um representative
gry this language in this bill is
directly pulled from our discussions in
the subcommittee our subcommittee
discussion result was that there's
already a Prohibition against music
therapists using um the or engaging in
the practice of Audiology or Speech
Pathology it's in their lure um it's in
their scope of practice under their RSA
that prohibits anyone from doing
anything in the such where they would be
C doing their scope of practice and so
it would be it would be redundant and
repetitive to put it in our bill as well
and so it was agreed upon in the
subcommittee meetings that it was not
necessary to put it in this bill because
it's already in their bill that you
cannot act as a speech or
audiologist sorry a follow up
please so miss Adams this language that
you're referring to as an
amendment describes ex what per
se uh it makes it clear in the music
therapist Practice Act uh which would
likely be the only one that a music
therapist would read um that they are
not uh able to treat a communication
disorder
itself
questions is there anyone else who
six I I have a a question will miss
Adams make that language available to
us yes absolutely I will send it to the
committee chair if that works yes
Kelly
you should be able to unmute yourself
Miss
Kelly okay can you hear me now yes
indeed good afternoon I'm Tina Kelly I'm
appearing before you on behalf of the
office of professional lure and certific
um oplc does not oppose nor support this
bill but we do however have some
concerns and I believe I've testified to
these
before but um one of the concerns is
that on page 38 line 11 it adds those
definitions listed there to RSA
328 those specific definitions should
remain solely in RSA 326m the proposed
legislation because if it's put into the
um Allied Health law they would
significantly significantly change the
meaning for the other Allied Health
boards the appropriate changes are
described on page 40 in line 22 and
those are being
added the second thing is that this bill
is being added to the LA Health boards
which are fully autonomous boards
receiving administrative support from
oplc
on page 40 line 14 it states under Roman
numeral 3 the executive director shall
seek and seek the advice of the board
for issues related to the regulation of
Music
therapists because of this requirement
under their duties it's unclear whether
this is meant to be an autonomous board
or an Advisory
board and the last thing I'll add is
that we wanted to be sure that on page
41 and it creates a new position if this
um legislation were to pass and oplc
would definitely need that position
although there wouldn't be a a lot of
these um of
lenses there would be there's much more
that goes into administering a board
development and Main maintenance of
rules
meetings um replying to questions of the
lenses in the public maintenance of a
database so if this does go through we
would definitely need that
position um this is all I have at the
this time if you have any questions I'd
them repr bro you have a
question thank you uh Miss Kelly in
regard to the new
um won't all or organizations that that
U all new organizations in oplc have the
same requirement so that we wouldn't how
is it that does that mean that for every
every new um group that we that was
brought under oplc you need a new
position to initiate all those changes
not necessarily but in this case
we we've added so much to our staff that
are already doing the licensing that at
some point it becomes um Although our
staff does a great job that just
overwhelmed with the amount of lenses so
adding a even a little bit more is just
going to create that much more work and
at some point every little bit becomes
UNS
sustainable yes represent brotto in if
the board already exists and is moved to
oplc IT staff would move with it this is
a brand new board
so their position is that they need
staff
thank you representative
Shu thank you madam chair um not sure
who to address this question to but uh
do we have an idea how many people would
be likely to apply for lure under this
um grouping we were discussing the house
bill it was between 30 and
you
other questions is there anyone else who
hand not seeing
any close part six move on to part seven
and
repres oh Grant
posy hi there I apologize uh Madam chair
I didn't have a rais hand button so I
just thought I'd unmute myself uh I am
here on behalf of Senator Kevin avard I
am Grant bossy majority policy director
for the New Hampshire Senate I apologize
for my tardan Senator avard had hoped to
be here himself he is the Prime on this
section of the bill uh he will be
submitting written testimony to you and
asks for your consideration of that and
other than that he apologizes for not
being able to be here in person and
would appreciate the committee's
consideration thank
you glad he sent
some
well set I do want to make one uh
administrative comment before we go on
to section
seven that is that part two which is a
compact will also be considered by
representative Roy's subcommittee on
occup on the occupational therapy and
Audiology compacts since they're
somewhat
related um hope it doesn't bother you
representative movich to lose that
section but but he
volunteered
[Music]
okay GNA open the hearing on uh part
133 Senator Reagan
here Senator Reagan is is not here and I
have uh reached out to him by email and
phone and have not uh succeeded
in um contacting him just so you know so
thank you representative McGuire would
the yes certainly this is more technical
cleanup on the oplc this deals with
hearings the the administration of
hearings and uh application procedures
and it includes the rul making authority
department again this is a lot of very
fine print that we will be examining
morning I believe it is
all essentially duplicative to existing
one law except that it
consolidates these activities under the
oplc rather than each individual
groa thank you Mr chair um is this then
similar to house
bill is it 58 the one that that Senator
Carson submitt that has
similar that has a similar
tone uh yes except that Senate Bill 58
deals with different topics that are
Consolidated that that deals with with
application
procedures um this one deals with Ru
rule making investigations and hearings
and appeals which are not covered in
Senate Bill 58 but the the intent is the
same
thank
questions is there anybody else who'd
like to speak on the bill please raise
so so so Mr Michael Porter has his hand
up yep I'm trying to get
like he Mr repter you should be able to
unmute
yourself ah there I am good afternoon uh
good afternoon uh Madam chair and
distinguished committee members so my
name is Mike Porter I'm an attorney I'm
also the administrator of oplc
enforcement um I had a long speech
prepared but I'm gonna I'm gonna reduce
it because I know you folks have have
sat through a lot of testimony today um
but I do want to discuss the primary
functions of oplc which as you all know
is to strengthen the workforce in New
Hampshire through ease of access of
professional
lure second uh through the enforcement
of statutes and rules governing
professional lure our mission is to
protect the health uh the health safety
and Welfare uh of the public while also
balancing the D process protections of
professional
lenses um the reason we have put this
forward to you is currently we have 55
boards commissions uh or councils
combined and right now we operate under
55 different sets of statutes and rules
um this has proven to be a tremendous uh
I guess uh undertaking when when trying
to follow a complaint process uh through
final adjudication and I I want to tell
you that since October 2020 uh the
senior leadership team we've met and
continue to meet with all the boards to
review a more efficient and effective
complaint process um as a result of
these meetings a number of boards have
signed on to um a new complaint process
through standing orders these standing
orders do allow complaints to be
centrally processed reviewed and
submitted uh to the
boards uh at an early stage uh
which then brings the final decision a
lot sooner than in the past and I can
tell you in the past we have had some
cases range anywhere from one to three
years um we feel that that does not
provide for an efficient or effective
complaint processing system number one
for those members of the public who have
legitimately filed a complaint but
number two it also doesn't benefit the
lensee to maybe be currently practicing
for one two or three years only to have
their case finally adjudicated and then
some sort of administrative discipline
issued so the proposed statutory changes
to the enforcement process does provide
the consistency and efficiency uh from
the filing of an initial complaint all
the way to final adjudication there are
no two cases that are alike uh the
manner in we in in which each case is
handled um should be similar and again
as I mentioned under the current
statutory scheme each board has a unique
complaints one of the central issues
that we find
um particularly bothersome is on the
final adjudication of complaints uh as I
said so in the past when a border
commission or Council issues a notice of
hearing the parties engage in settlement
negotiations unfortunately some of these
cases may not be resolved through either
settlement or fral adjudication ranging
anywhere from one to three years we are
currently working on a process
internally where if a board requests a
matter for adjudication we have 60 days
from the date that they request that to
settle the matter and if it's not
settled on day 60 we then issue the
notice of hearing and the the matter is
scheduled to be heard within 30
days this places the matter before the
boards commissions and Council councils
within what we believe is a reasonable
time period resulting in the issuance of
final determination of complaints in a
timely efficient and effective
manner what's primary here as well is
throughout all of these changes that
we've made there and I and I need to be
crystal clear the boards are not
relinquishing any rights Power Authority
or any of that nature every board
commission and councel has absolute
final say on every case that any
complaint that is filed before their
board
many of the boards and commissions and
councils have as I mentioned been
utilizing this streamline process
through standing orders currently the
Board of Medicine Board of Nursing
barbering cosmetology and Aesthetics
accountancy and many more are following
this since we started this enforcement
division in September 1st of 2020 we
have processed
1,198 complaints of these nearly 2,000
cases we've also handled 22 emergency
suspensions for matters involving
imminent danger to the public health
safety and or welfare in addition to the
emergency suspensions we've handled a
number of preliminary agreements not to
practice that's in lie of a suspension
um pending the outcome of an
investigation all of this is an effort
to protect the public health safety and
Welfare the pros to the proposal are
numerous but most important this process
allows for the immediate protection of
the public health safety and Welfare and
by that what I mean is all complaints
come through a centralized process we
have two individuals that screen every
single complaint they're trained to look
for items that may be in imminent danger
to the public health safety and Welfare
they then bring that directly to me i t
i review the matter pull up the statutes
and rules right away and then I go to
our chief prosecutor um this all happens
literally within less than an hour's
time if we deem at that point that
there's an emergency where we have to
emergently suspend a professional
license we then R raise this level to
the executive director who has final say
um I want to reiterate that the boards
commissions and councils throughout this
entire process um have have no
diminished authority of the of their of
of the boards there's none uh they will
have the ability to address matters and
timely consistent and efficient manner
all the while retaining jurisdiction
over every case that comes before them I
just want to give you a very brief
sampling of some of the cases that we've
handled since September 1st um which
were the result of our initial screeners
uh through this centralized process um
in December 2020 we were made made aware
of an individual engaged in the
unlicensed practice of medicine whereby
the individual had women expose
themselves while he conducted
examinations uh um the Board of Medicine
does in fact have jurisdiction over
unlicensed practice of medicine uh we
were able to
successfully prosecute that matter uh we
investigated the matter in less than 30
days um we adjudicated the matter before
the Board of Medicine uh in March of
this year uh utilizing our investigative
staff and our prosecution division
another matter we were made aware of I
believe was October or November was a
speech language path olist who engage in
an assaul of behavior of a
three-year-old Child by angrily
suspending the child by his ankles
inches above a school building floor and
then proceeding to drag that child by
the arm down a hallway we were
immediately able to suspend the license
of that leny and move forward with
adjudication during the height of covid
uh we received information of a
pharmacist diverting a dose of madna
covid-19 vaccine from a hospital we were
able to secure a preliminary agreement
not not to practice pending the outcome
of an
investigation in October of 2020 some of
you may have heard about this case uh we
were made aware of unsavory business
practices of a for-profit post-secondary
nursing school in Manchester which
caused students uh enrolled with
financial hardship within four days of
receiving the initial complaint and
Report through our investigation through
our new streamline process we were able
to immediately suspend the operation of
the school to prevent further Financial
harm
more important at final adjudication the
Board of Nursing revoked the for-profit
school's authority to practice in New
Hampshire thereby permanently
safeguarding students from further
Financial harm and another one more
recently involved another licensed
professional uh who the allegation was
engaged in possible sexual assault on a
client of theirs uh we immediately
suspended the license notified the
police department and as of last Sunday
this individual was arrested on on
aggravated fonia sexual assault this is
just a small sampling of matters that
we've pursued aggressively efficiently
and effectively to protect the public
health safety and Welfare all while also
ensuring that the lenses du process
protections are provided I also want to
say one last comment about this
particular Bill uh in the rule writing
portion um it also brings unlicensed
practice to all boards uh right now I
believe we only have a handful Maybe
maybe five boards total that actually
have jurisdiction over unlicensed
practice I can tell you about one case
that uh is is uh going to be heard and
involves U removal wrongful removal of
escrow funds to the tune of about30 or
$140,000 um these cases are cases that
we are immediately able to engage in um
and because of the ability to go after
somebody like that we can prevent
further harm we recently settled three
unlicensed real estate practice cases
where we were able to utilize the
statutory language we could not
determine the economic gain that the out
ofst State Realtors gained but we were
able to issue a $10,000 fine as a Max
Fine to each
individual these are just some of the
processes that are identified in the
bill and and uh I can tell you as
someone who has been uh with this
enforcement division since day one and
helping build it we have seen a
tremendous benefit to the public health
safety and Welfare but we've also heard
from the civil defense bar that they
feel that their clients are being
offered due process protections which uh
they believe is a step in the right
direction so with that I'm I'm
submitting my testimony and I'm I'm
happy to answer any
questions representative citech Mr
Porter are you doing anything special
tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock
well I am supposed to be in the Board of
Nursing uh meeting but I I believe I can
probably get somebody to fill
in we might have some questions for you
uh at that time additional questions
detail I'd be happy to join you at 10
o'clock
any uh you there's a one of the things
I'll develop then but I'll just tell you
this is strange here the oplc
is going after somebody who for
aggravated fonus assault
for a quack esy women to expose
themselves Can You Reach people who
aren't uh you're not police how do you
reach people who aren't license I mean
these are criminal offenses we're
talking
about correct that's a great question
and I will be brief um so with the um
unlicensed uh practice of medicine that
came in as a complaint um
and we investigated it to determine
whether we had jurisdiction under the
Board of Medicine statutes the Board of
Medicine in fact can reach unlicensed
individuals uh we can issue a a cease
and desist U if found uh in violation of
that statute uh the Board of Medicine
can issue up to a $50,000 fine and it is
also essentially a per se misdemeanor um
in this particular matter when we
received the ma that particular case we
did make the referral to the appropriate
police department at the same time um so
that we could do a parallel
investigation on the other individual
with the aggravated fonia sexual assault
uh that came in with a potential concern
um of what we call unprofessional
conduct under our statute when we were
able to dig into uh the information a
little bit deeper um not only did we
suspend him but we immediately I
personally contacted the Nashville
Police Department that same day and made
a report and handed over all the
information that we had um so that we
could make sure so they're parallel
investigations um but we do have the
authority on several boards to reach out
to unlicensed
practice thank youve done 90% of my
interest thank you representative
Shu thank you Mr chair uh so Mr Porter
is it fair to say that if someone is
doing a criminal activity in addition to
unlicensed practice uh you could take
immediate steps whereas criminal
prosecution would be a much longer
process uh that is correct and and and
and I do want to mention this we had
recently received a report of a nurse
who broke the fingers of an elderly
patient in a long-term care facility um
we were notified the day of the arrest
but you know that person could make bail
and potentially work in that profession
again we immediately suspended that
person's license I think uh we received
the report at 409m by 5:15 pm that
person's license was suspended um and
she just entered into a preliminary
agreement not to practice uh which under
emergency suspensions they have the
right to be heard within 10 days but
under a preliminary agreement not to
practice it extends it out so that we
can conduct our complete
investigation thank you thank
representative thank you Mr
chairman uh my question involves um you
know the the the bulk of what we're
talking about in reference to to this m
this massive thing that the Senate has
sent us and that is with with your
investigative part of things and and the
look that you guys give to these
situations would you expect that a New
Hampshire license e that was having a
problem in say Arizona come before your
investigative
team and they would handle that or you
would handle that and then vice versa if
we had a if we had someone from
Pennsylvania practicing in New Hampshire
would you expect the investigation would
be solely conducted by you or would this
involve the jurisdiction with the
primary license he operates
from that is a loaded question so I'll
I'll tell you this um we will cooperate
with any other uh licensing body and so
for example we had a situation with a
hospital in Boston Massachusetts where
the individual was there on a on a
temporary license uh we held the
permanent license and so they reported
to us U the the the issue and we
conducted the well Massachusetts is
conducting their investigation but
because of the report we're doing a
simultaneous
investigation if a New Hampshire Len he
engages a misconduct in another state um
and we do find out about it we
absolutely have the jurisdiction under
our statutes uh to conduct an
investigation to ensure that no statutes
of ours were violated if a statute is
different in another state than ours uh
we haven't re we haven't crossed that
bridge yet um but if we do we would also
probably seek guidance from our general
that one second chair have a follow
follow thank
you so so basically you know as a
general rule there's got to be one group
of people that that are in charge here
so has this been worked out with these
compacts are you aware of how this how
this handles you know when the when
these situations come down as far as who
actually is the lead because because
that needs to be defined If It Isn't So
yeah if if the violation occurs in the
state of New Hampshire we are the lead
um and what happen and I can I'll
explain it under the nursing uh Practice
Act that's the largest compact lure I
believe that we have um we have
individuals here who might engage in uh
unprofessional conduct we will take the
investigative lead um if we deem that
that conduct does rise to the level of
violation we will notify the home state
as well because what happens is a nurse
here on a multi-state compact for
example um we under the under the the
compact lure and I forget which section
it is I can visualize it but uh we have
the primary ability to to investigate
and hold accountable by the way even
though they're it's a multi-state
license but once we once we've reached
that adjudication stage or even prior to
if we deem it to be emergent we not only
will report to nurses or the National
Practitioner database but we will
actually contact the home state directly
just to make sure that there's no
misinformation or there's no cross
signals um because in some cases we've
actually had some nurses who one case in
particular was kind of a catch me if you
can uh well we caught her um she was up
here but lived down south uh we
emergently suspended her and she
essentially ignored us until I believe
she had a knock on her door from her
home state uh U suspending her abilities
as well so we have a being centralized
the way we are right now U and it's
through standing orders um really gives
us that that jump that Head
Start and I want to be clear these are
the more severe cases um I will tell you
this is less than I think even a half a
percent of our lenses I would say um 99%
of our lenses are acting with within the
professional guidelines but these are
some of the worst of the worst that we
do
see thank you representative
scitech okay thank you any other
Porter um I don't know if there's anyone
else signed up to speak on this section
I'm not aware of
one so is there anyone who uh else who'
like to speak on this uh section
ofb
hand they seen none I'm going to close
133 and Senator Ward is here for Section
Eight Mr
chairman excellent that case I open the
hearing on eight and I call Senator
Ward
her
okay can you hear me now yes thank you
thank you very much thank you Mr chair
and the members of the committee uh I'm
taking care of part eight of s SP
133 has to do with a skilled
professional medical
personnel uh long-term care has to do
with eligibility and service coverage
authorization skilled professional
medical personnel employed by or
designated to act on behalf of the
department shall determine clinical
eligibility in accordance with the
criteria in sub paragraph one
parenthesis a and I will go a little bit
further
down the person shall train all person
all all people performing the assessment
and the most important part is that the
only skilled professional medical
personnel who are registered nurses and
currently licensed in accordance with
RSA
ility
determination thank you Mr
chair thank you Senator are there any
questions of the committee for for
Senator
any would whoever I know there are some
other people who wish to testify in this
section so could you raise your hands
up Douglas auster house mute yourself
here
hello Madam chair this is Douglas
osterhout did you just call on me I had
a technical glitch you were promoted to
a panelist so we can all hear you all
right thank you madam chair and members
of the committee my name is Douglas
osterhout and I am with the Bureau of
general counsel for the Department of
Health and Human Services I actually
have a colleague with me here today
Wendy Alman she is the bureau chief for
the Bureau of elderly and Adult Services
and uh with your permission I'd like to
have her unmuted just in case there are
any questions that she she has been
brought forward as a
panelist thank you very much so I'll be
brief I know time is short today um but
we're here to request the removal of
part A from the bill as it pertains to
those um skilled professional medical
personnel and limiting those P permitted
to render adverse clinical eligibility
determinations to only registered nurses
currently licensed in according with RSA
326b so Senator John Reagan sponsored
sb49 in 2015 to change the language
identifying who's permitted to make
those determinations from registered
nurse to Skilled professional medical
personnel this was at the Department's
request and we testified in favor of
this change as it would broaden the
scope of individuals under the law
permitted to conduct clinical
eligibility assessments and issue
determination so for example by allowing
uh for API RNs to conduct assessments
and we did this so that the department
could fe uh fill key positions and avoid
delays in the provision of services to
the citizens of New Hampshire prior to
that change the limiting language had at
certain times placed the department in
the position of being unable to fill the
roles of those tasked with issuing
determinations uh which in turn led to
delays in issuing decisions which again
in turn LED in to delays in services and
that's something uh we're trying to
avoid so the second thing I'd like to
address quickly with you is that the
language of proposed paragraph 3A would
require skilled professional medical
personnel to oversee service service
coverage prior authorizations for
Medicaid Home and Community Care waiver
Services that's the CFI program here in
New Hampshire choices for
Independence um it's not necessary to
meet the definition of skilled
professional medical personnel in order
to administer or supervise staff of a
program in which staff render
determinations this language as proposed
singles out the department and
Department staff who administer these
programs
me sorry about that and places
restrictions on uh program
administrators and supervised Beyond
those required for similarly situated
entities so just to give you an example
there's no requirement that an
administrator or supervisor of a nursing
facility meet that definition so I had a
conversation with uh oplc and they
confirmed that non-clinical Personnel
May supervise clinical Personnel uh it's
the L who's responsible for their
clinical decisions uh additionally
there's no specialized training included
in skilled Professional Medical
Personnel training uh for example that
of a registered nurse that would provide
the trainee with administrative or
supervisor capabilities Beyond those of
Administrators or supervisors who
haven't undergone similar training
Additionally the language in threea
would limit those permitted to render
adverse service coverage determinations
to only registered nurses and that would
require the department to devote
medically trained staff to render
adverse determinations
for requests that might be denied for
non-clinical reasons so for example an
incomplete application or a failure to
exhaust third party liability denials
like these they're they do not need the
specific skill set of a registered nurse
they're programmatic or administrative
in nature and the third point I want to
address today is that the language of
proposed parag five defines skilled
professional medical personnel as having
432.32 to the requirement that only
registered nurses May render adverse
clinical eligibility or service coverage
determination creates additional
exceptions to the definition um which by
the way includes Physicians dentists
nurses other specialized personnel with
professional Education and Training and
so this additional exception results in
the definition of skilled Prof excuse me
skilled professional medical personnel
being more restrictive than the federal
definition and places additional
restrictions on who may render adverse
determinations uh so for example under
the current more encompassing definition
an APRN uh would be able to render an
adverse determination under the proposed
definition in conjunction with some
other language in the bill um they would
be prohibited from doing so uh
additionally and this is my final point
when s sp49 was introduced in 2015 a
subcomittee of the house Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee
worked to to hone in on that definition
of skilled professional medical
personnel and made that decision to
432.32 50 D12 little I um would be very
confusing um and they chose that
definition for its Reliance on the use
of the term professional education
andain training so again we are asking
for removal of part nine I am available
for
questions uh both today and any and any
subcommittees you may need me in I hope
you're you're talking about section
eight because that's what it is now that
what was I
saying okay are there questions
representative
goalie thank you madam chair Madam chair
this is more of a question to you will
we get some input from Health and Human
Services committee on this I think this
mostly deals with
their uh topic subject topic than ours
yes it good point I will send a note to
the chair and ask them to comment on it
or support the
Schmidt thank you madam chair um so I I
have uh some questions because as much
as Mr osterhout is a very expert in the
subject uh for those of us who are not
and I include myself in that category uh
some of it is a little bit uh a forest
of uh uh technical terms which are not
necessarily Illuminating uh for the uh
unskilled practitioner again including
myself um so uh you're talking about
determinations adverse determinations so
this this means you're turning people
treatment so the thank you for your
question representative the CFI choices
for Independence program which this bill
covers that's the uh what is the I want
to make sure I get the home and
communitybased Care waiver services so
essentially Medicaid would require an
individual to be in a nursing home CFI
program is a program that allows
individuals to stay in their home and
receive services so yes when I'm talking
about eligibility it would be a denial
of those Services Under that
application okay
followup uh yes before you ask your next
question I would would these
adverse determinations also affect
eligibility to receive Medicaid care in
home uh thank you for your question no I
don't believe so I believe these are
limited to the um 1915c choices for
Independence waiver program uh just to
clarify so so everyone's on the same
page the CFI program does use the same
eligibility criteria as Nursing Facility
elig ability that's 151
E3 thank you representative Schmid
please ask question well okay so uh the
question of the chair is this going to
The subcommittee Madam chair why yes
representative Schmidt every part of
this bill is going to sub okay excellent
because some of this I think should be
explored in the subcommittee more than
we can under these circumstances but uh
so M Mr Oster how my next question is
we're not talking about treat for people
being uh rendered by people who are not
uh at least nursing uh trained
individuals we're not talking about
treatment we're talking
about the eligibility for treatment
that's being decided on is that correct
correct representative so the way it
currently works is the department
subcontracts with a company called
keypro um keypro sends a registered
nurse and uses a medical Eligibility
Assessment tool as required by staff
statue and does a face the face
interview with the individual um and
then if person is found open for
services then they are open if not that
means enrolled in the program sorry um
and if not then it's sent to the
department and we do a deeper Dive by
taking a look at the individual's
medical records and uh it's a rigorous
process you have to go through at least
three reviews by skilled professional
medic Medical Personnel one being KEPR
two in the department we have three
individuals who do that um currently all
three are RNs and you have to have all
three of those individuals both the Keo
and nursing staff here say no before
you're denied from the program but it is
to your question strictly for
eligibility purposes and not the people
providing the Hands-On
service okay so if I understand
correctly the um followup uh so if I
understand correctly the uh this
procedure has been in effect since
approx approximately 2015 is it working
well in the opinion of the
department yes
sir followup followup is there anything
unusual about this procedure in terms of
how other states handle it if it's
working
well that's information I do not have
repr okay uh we'll look at it in the
sir are there any other
questions is there is there anyone else
Eight see any
Marling is Senator Hennessy with
yes so you should be able to unmute
us can you hear me now yes there you are
okay thank you I am here to introduce
part nine which is on page 48 of the
bill and it is relative to Temporary
lure of certified licensed nursing
assistance and what this does is um
allow the recognition of the hard work
of those people who completed an 8-hour
training course and became temporary
Health Care Health Providers Health Care
Providers during the covid pandemic and
these people were very critical in
serving the needs of especially our um
our nursing homes in in the pandemic
time and this would allow those
individuals who have uh done this online
training and had no fewer than a 100
hours of work under other licensed
professionals um in the um healthc care
field um to be recognized as lnas if
they've also completed the required um
lnas so that uh if I understand
correctly you're saying that these
people can take an online course and
serve for 100 hours and then be eligible
for lure as an LNA yes that's correct
and there are other people on the line
that um are much more um knowledgeable
about the the entire process and how
many individuals um this will affect but
there are at least
1,000 um there's a at least a thousand
LNA shortage of of Workforce shortage in
the state currently and this would just
make a a little bit of dent in that
population that we're looking to
fill thank
you BR you have a
question thank you Madame chair Senator
Hennessy this is there um restricted to
a certain group of people it's not
something that would be
ongoing no uh thank you for the question
uh this is not ongoing it is restricted
to those who have completed a 100 hours
or more by April 1 of this of this year
thank
you
yes yes uh actually Senator Hennessy why
wouldn't we want to continue this
program since such a shortage of
Ln that that is a great question and I
am I am happy to support an extension of
that deadline if the committee so
you representative fellows you have a
question thank you madam chair um
senator hnis see I'm just curious about
the 100 hours and how you came up with
that amount because that's not a lot I
mean that's less than three weeks of of
actually doing this it's kind of like
apprenticeship three hours of
apprenticeship how does that compare
with the standard training program for
the
lnas representative thank you for that
question I do not have the answer to
that someone else testifying will have
the
professional
so are there other questions for for the
senator seeing
none thank you madam chair and I
apologize I believe I forgot to
introduce myself Aaron Hennessy Senate
you would whoever else wishes to testify
on section nine please raise your hand
and recognize
Rosenberg yes good morning good
afternoon I'm sorry it is afternoon uh
Madam chair and member members of the
committee I'm Teresa Rosenberger I work
for the law firm of Brin Shure and I am
here representing the New Hampshire
healthc care
Association and let me just give you a
little bit of history about this when Co
started as we all remember last last uh
um March the federal government uh
extended a waiver for states allowing
temperary nurses AIDS and nursing homes
with limited training as you will
remember um the federal government also
put in their $600 stien for people who
um chose for one reason or another uh
not to go to not to work during Co
because of child care issues Health Care
issues ETC so once they put in that $600
stien on top of unemployment the nursing
homes were losing a lot of Staff um so
this Federal waiver was really a huge
help and what ended up happening is New
Hampshire uh called these people
temporary health partners and they were
authorized to work in the nursing homes
under licensed staff supervision by an
emergency order 42 that the governor put
into effect May 11th uh these were
workers I have to say provided
invaluable help and assistance they were
always supervised by lient staff but
they really really helped therefore
while we were having to even have people
who were um working in Food Service come
in and help help with residents it was
it was it was a bit of a a bit of a mess
um as Senator Hennessy said the New
Hampshire has experienced a huge
shortage of uh licensed nurs assistance
we went from June of
2018 um to June of 200 and may of 2020
year 22 years we suffered a net loss of
uh nearly 1300 licensed nursing
assistance and that's a tremendous loss
of really valuable um staff and we also
unfortunately have a number of licensed
nursing assistants going to
Massachusetts because you can uh imagine
there's a lot better pay in
Massachusetts particularly with
hospitals Etc so we've had a real
shortage
um to say that this uh language that
Senator Hennessy has has introduced it's
going to solve the problem no but it is
a real help at a time we still very much
need um need workers in the in the
nursing homes it's a it's a step forward
um these are are men and women who've
shown interest in health care and in in
nursing being nursing assistants and
they've really been an integral part of
the system for the last Almost um uh
year plus so we appreciate the bip part
support we appreciate Senator Hennessy
doing this and we just really would ask
you uh if you could move this forward
because we very much need need the help
and I'm happy to answer any questions
that I can thank you representative fra
you have a
question I do thank you Madame chair
this is not the first time um sen U Miss
Rosenberger that we've heard about um
people leaving the state because we
don't have adequate pay right and
therefore can we do something about our
standards to so that people who don't
meet them but are willing to take the
pay get the
work how do you feel
that
we bring the people that are at that are
that are working at this special
level to eventually meet the criteria
state I'm I'm not quite sure I
understand the question but let me
respond and then I'd love it if you'd
ask me again um the way this has worked
and we did work with the the um Nurses
Association with it when this started I
will say representative gry back in last
March lots of conversation and and
collaboration with the nursing
association
oplc um the the organizations that train
the nurses and the licensed nursing
assistants and so the program we came up
with for the temporary uh the temporary
um nursing license nursing assistance
was really worked in collaboration with
with all of them um if you see in the
bill there's criteria in there that you
have to have so many hours of training
that you have to work so many hours as a
temporary uh uh Health partner that you
had to be doing this by a certain date
and that also uh the important part of
it is one of the things the Nurses
Association wanted is that you you're
required to do continuing education so
we've tried to make this as um I guess I
would say as finite as possible and make
sure that these men and women are
supervised by licensed nurses but we are
giving them credit frankly for the work
they are doing while they have been in
this temporary position uh during Co so
they've gotten some valuable experience
I will say probably more so than they
would have without Co because the
staffing has been such and they've
they've really it's been a all hands on
deck uh situation so I don't know if
that answered your question it was an
attempt it was a very good attempt um
thank you I I do have a follow-up
question though I'm followup thank you
I'm commenting
um I'm I'm responding to the comment
that was made um the question there this
previously should we make this a
standard operating
procedure well I I will speak I will ask
my client but I will speak with great
knowledge of uh my client and their
constituents meaning the nursing homes
um I would say yes the the the short
shortage of Staff has just been
unbelievable we have administrators I
was on the phone this morning um with
with an administrator who said you know
she's now having to roll up her sleeves
and go in to give care she stayed in
this administrator is in the North
Country this nursing home administ and
she said they have contracts with 10
staffing agencies looking for staff to
help and as you can well imagine if
you're having go through a staffing
agency to get help you're paying top
dollar because you've got people coming
in from out of state helping and the and
the costs are quite they're high but she
said we not even being able to get
people from the staffing agencies to
come in in the North country and here
she is the administrator is going to
start giving Direct Care um so I think
anything the state can do to help this
situation would be terrific this is a
small step there are other things
obviously we would um love to Advocate
not so much so in this bill but but it
it's it's a help I was on the call every
Friday during the pandemic and now it's
every other week with these folks who
running the nursing homes and it was
they are doing God's work it was amazing
what they were doing what they were what
was going on and what the lack of staff
was really the problem it was creating
the temporary licensed nursing
assistance was a huge help at a really
crisis time so I longwind way of saying
yes I think if you would like to do it
for the long term that would be great
we'll take any help we can get so I have
a I have a last question Madam chair yes
representative thank you if we were to
do this then would
the how would this um work without
care may I ask what you mean by quality
Care well let's just say that we have
standards now that are met based on what
we think provides quality care to the V
right right so if we were to I'm going
just use the Expression lower the bar
yes okay and then how do we make know
that when we lower the bar the bar
doesn't stay
low right and so what would be the
gradual What would could could there be
a program in implemented so that okay
the bar starts low but then there is a
stepup curve to meet the current
standard let me get back to you on that
but I will say that I think in all the
conversations from when this first
started the thought was you had people
who were out of work who might uh and
particularly in the food service
industry Etc who might be looking for
change in professions so if we could get
them in give them a try see if they
liked it and then they could go through
the process of actually becoming um
lnas and so I think everybody's thought
initially was one this was helped but
was also getting people into the system
to see if they
they were cut out for the work and then
through that let them get hands-on
experience as well as go through some
some education and eventually become a
licensed nursing assistant thank you so
much and thank you m welcome and I will
get back to you I'll give you I'll send
you some written information on that as
well all right thank you the idea is
this is this is a gateway frankly to
getting people into the system that are
licensed
you thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my
question uh
I don't know if you have the answer
right now or if you could get it for us
do you know what the average entry wage
is of an LNA that nursing homes have
pay I don't but uh I can give you a good
guess but I don't but I do know that one
of the issues frankly has been
representing goalie that we' and it's
not just nursing homes who have limited
staff it's hospitals as well and
hospitals are much more well capitalized
than nursing homes um so unfortunately
well in fact on the call this morning
there was a woman who said they had
three people who came in and they were
trained in an LNA program in their
facility they worked and the Hope was
again this was an entry level into these
people being there uh one of them left
and went to Massachusetts and and the
other one went right down the street to
the local hospital because they can pay
more and I think the hospitals maybe are
paying ,750 or so an hour and probably
the nursing homes starting are around 12
um as you know I could get really
complicated into this but this not the
Edna committee part of the real issue
here represent goalie is the Medicaid
reimbursement rates and with Medicaid
reimbursement rates not what they should
be the the nursing homes have no they
they can't pay what a hospital can
pay because the rates the rates are way
too low and frankly it would be great if
the the the finance committee would
somehow or another raise those Medicaid
reimbursement rates we could certainly
pay more so follow up follow
yes
so qualifications may not be the
complete issue wages may be another
factor in this correct oh wages Wages
that's absolutely not a question wages
are a big issue and what you've got
right now in the nursing homes is
because when covid hit you couldn't take
patients who were tested positive for
covid and so all of a sudden the census
coming from the hospitals was less
because you get a number of people
referred to nursing homes that are
coming from hospitals that need rehab um
so your census was last people weren't
coming in for one reason or another so
right now you've got decreased number of
people in the home
the if I could find my notes from this
morning I'll tell you this is just what
that we were told by this Nursing Home
in the North Country this morning cost
are up
58% wages are up 34% and that's because
they're having to get staff from
staffing agencies at of State um the
occupancy rate is is down and the
revenue is down
27% and that's you know that's you got
you wages is absolutely a problem but
this bill is not solving that problem
we're hoping other committees and the
Senate and the house will will help with
that but this would just really help um
get some bodies in those spaces
particularly of people who want to
consider a career and be trained and
paid while they're being
trained thank you're welcome
representative
fellows thank you madam chair um I'm
wondering if you can help me with this
um I'm concerned that if the requirement
is only a 100 hours on the job that some
of these temporary lnas were worked in
one facility doing one task and that
they're not qualified for all the tasks
that um one would expect of an an LNA
that went through the regular program
can you address that well I think that's
these are temporary they're temporary
licensed nursing assistants they're not
permanent so they they are coming in on
a temporary basis if they want to be an
LNA they need to go through a re a
regular LNA they need to go through an
LNA
program
which the way this is set up they and
they have to have done this by April 1st
of
so unless you have been in a nursing
home as a temporary health partner by
April 1st of 20121 you don't
qualify and representative fellows you
should be aware that the LNA is the
lowest level of licensed health
professionals right and the education
requirements are not that strict for
initial lure but the continuing
education requirements are fairly
uncommon so I I still would would is
there somebody else that's going to come
up that can answer the questions about
like what the skills are that they're
expected to have the reg under the
regular license
method I can get that to you if you if
you'd like you you want to know the
skills of the license um the they the
lnas correct
okay and if you could get the normal
hours of training yeah right that would
be useful because all I remember from
the study committee was that uh at least
a couple of high schools in the state
have part-time training programs that
qualify people for an LNA license right
essentially before they even
graduate although you can't get it
graduate that's
right I will get you the um skill level
and I'll get your comparison
representative fellas thank you Mr
renberger you're welcome are there any
other
questions see none is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on part nine so
hand no don't see any
so we'll close the hearing on part
10 see the senator for part
10 Senator Apprentice has her hand up
you okay I'll open the hearing on part
[Music]
promoted great Senator Apprentice I you
should be able to unmute
yourself um thank you very much uh good
afternoon uh chairman Maguire and
members of um house executive
departments and
administration um my name is Su Prentice
I'm the state senator from District Five
I am a paramedic and I'm also the former
Chief of Emergency Medical Services in
the state of New Hampshire so it's
fitting that I would be bringing the
section of um of Senate Bill 133 to you
which is part 10 this is a relative I'm
introducing the section that's relative
to the revocation
of lure for licensed Emergency Medical
Service units and Emergency Medical
Service Vehicles as well as
Personnel so there are two things that
this piece of legislation wishes to
accomplish uh one is to align our
suspension and revocation process for
for for personnel in particular with the
other healthc care professions which
I'll review with you in terms of nursing
um and Physicians and the second is as
part of this promoting just culture um
in the performance Improvement um again
for Emergency Medical Services
professionals licensed Professionals in
New Hampshire like our other healthc
care profession Partners so back on
November 19th of 2020 the state EMS
medical control board voted um
unanimously to support a change in the
language to New Hampshire RSA 153 a13
requiring revocation of
lure from the commissioner saying that
the commissioner shall deny an
application for issuance or renewal of a
license or suspend or revoke a license
when the commissioner finds that the
applicant is guilty of any of the
following acts and offenses and it it
lists out those but the key word in here
is that the commissioner shall um deny
and then again it provides a list and so
this language does not align with the
other medical professions within the
state so if we look at Physicians and
surgeons under chapter 3291
17 um chapter 320 for the nurses it
would be 326b of the nurse Practice
Act oh we've got uh SEC b37 chapter 328d
for Physicians assistance as also for
dentists and Dentistry section 317
a17 um they don't don't have shall they
use May allowing for um discretion um
and also promoting the ability to use
just culture which again is pra so this
is something when we talk about just
culture this means that an act or an
offense which could be is minor and does
not at the discretion of the
commissioner require suspension or lure
but has been elevated to the
commissioner's level he could instead of
denying he or she denying or suspending
A license they could put a letter of
concern in the file um which is part of
just culture which says this mistake was
made um we this is how it has been
remedied and here it exists in this
person's file this is again a practice
that um is found throughout Healthcare
um and it promotes more openness more
transparency and more opportunities um
for learning so um with that again I'll
I'll stop and just ask that you consider
changing the language from shall to May
um in 153 a13 give the commissioner of
the discretion to issue letters of
concern as Parts as a part of just
culture um and this does not change the
commissioner's ability to suspend or to
revoke but at puts another key tool um
in the toolbox for licensed
professionals and Emergency Medical
Services and puts it on the record
should there be an issue that needs to
be addressed thank you thank you any
Apprentice
seen representative
Shu thank you Mr chair good afternoon
Senator Apprentice um I'm curious uh
when you were the head of Emergency
Medical Services I understood that that
was your position at one time did you
encounter any instances where this would
have been a tool that you would have
used yes um I did encounter instances
where was a tool that we could have used
a good example so I haven't been in that
position since 2010 so I'm going to use
my memory here would be you would be um
normally local medical directors work
with local EMS professionals they know
them the best and so let's say there
were two medications that could be used
for a certain problem one was used it
wasn't the best choice it didn't hurt
the patient but there would have been a
better
choice a local medical director would
normally handle that but if for some
reason somebody decided to write a
complaint that came to the
commissioner's office or to the Bureau
of EMS and mul to the commissioner then
their only opportunity to act on this
would be to deny would be to suspend or
revoke um and that doesn't promote good
patient it doesn't promote safety it
doesn't promote transparency um and it's
and it really is limiting where if this
sort to happen in again in an
organization and happen locally it would
be handled it would be documented um and
we would all be better for that so that
would be the kind of example that um we
had come before us that we we were we
were limited on how to um on how to
manage thank you I think that gives us a
better handle on what we're talking
about here yeah thank thank you
representative
fellows uh thank you Mr chair um M I
have two
questions one of them the letter of
concern is that something that goes in
their file or what happens with that
letter I have a followup question too
absolutely so Madam Cher if it's okay
I'll take
both Pro proed or or sorry whoever um so
they the licensed professional would get
a copy U and then it would also be part
of the record in the Bureau of Emergency
Medical
Services okay and my followup question
is if you change the shall to May that
opens up the
possibility that a person who is guilty
of any of the following Acts or offenses
that the action taken is nothing at all
because the May means you don't have to
do any of these is that your intent no
it's not our intent but it's our intent
to give flexibility to the commissioner
um to make the decision whether it's
whether they'll take one of these three
actions instead of nothing at all or
only have two um it's never been my
experience and I have been out of this
position for a while that when there was
an issue that needed to be dealt with
that it wasn't handled appropriately so
they'll they can still suspend or revoke
and they would be in a I would I can't
imagine a position or a situation where
if they had if they were guilty or what
is called founded in the licensure
process that they wouldn't take one of
those
actions well I'm not a commissioner I
can't speak for them but that's what my
what I would do so just followup follow
up
so the way I read it is that if that
word shall stays there you will get
exactly what you just explained putting
the word May in there gives them the
option to do none of those things do you
do you see that or um I understand what
you're saying but I I don't I don't
necess I don't necessarily agree the
intent is not to wipe the Slate clean it
is to provide discretion and in the very
beginning representative Fells if I may
I mentioned that or I stated that
nursing uh Physicians other health care
professions their boards not not
Commissioners but they have Boards of
oversight that do the same kind of work
they have that same language they're
given that same discretion and so if
they're providing patient care and so as
Emergency Medical Services again I can't
see how this would be any handled any
differently okay thank you you are so
Apprentice see none uh is there anyone
else who'd like to speak on this bill
the section of this
bill okay uh director
romanello Justin you should be able to
unmute
yourself good afternoon thank you sir um
again my name is Justin romanell I'm the
chief the Bureau of Ems for the State of
New Hampshire and um I don't want to
Echo everything that c Senator
Apprentice said um but the the tool here
is is to give the commissioner a few
options um what we've done in the in the
past or what what he has done in the
past is um in a case where uh we we
intend for the letter of concern to be
used um we've what we've done is he's
he's either a revoked the license or
suspended a license in abeyance um and
so it's still on the individual's record
um but they wouldn't actually have an
action taken um directly on their
license unless theyve they've committed
a a follow-up action in a in a time per
period that was determined um so where I
see this being utilized would be um in
cases that we have may have done that in
the past and I apologize I I don't have
an example for you um but where an
action may not have been Justified to
take against the license
where a letter of concern would have
been more appropriate for that
individual but the only option that the
commissioner had at the time was to take
the action against the license um as
Senator Apprentice did say um you know
we're not trying to to um give the
commissioner the flexibility to not act
just to act more appropriately um and
provide those those those options for
him or her um also as Senator prus
mentioned you know you know what we also
are trying to do is is is create that
just culture um I I think what keeps me
up more at night is is the stuff we
don't hear about um and the stuff that
people are afraid to to to to give us as
far as complaints um for us to perform
in investigation um because of the only
options that that are had are in fact a
revocation or a suspension um so I think
by changing the the word into May um
from Sha and adding the letter of
concern as as a tool um this will put us
more in line with the other health care
professions that Senator Apprentice
mentioned um in thus create in that same
just culture that we we see in those
Industries um I appreciate the time and
conly answer any questions if anybody
questions I see none is there anyone
else who'd like to speak on uh section
10 of
s133
see none I'm going to close the hearing
on this section of the
you
next and Senator Reagan is the prime
sponsor for the next couple of sections
I have left a phone message and emailed
but I have not heard from him okay thank
you
sponsor all right I'll open the hearing
on Section 11 of SB 133 and recognize
our representative McGuire to speak on
it thank you I'm Carol McGuire
representing merac District 29 which is
the towns of Allenstown Epsom and
Pittsfield and part 11 is a change to
the definition of a school for barbering
cosmetology M by allowing a dedicated
program to be counted as a school and
it's not doesn't have to be a completely
independent
program for example you could have a
dedicated program within a high school
and I believe that's one of the places
where they're interested in
it it also
aot requires a Apprentice in such a
program to register with the board Bo
and gets an apprentice
certificate which is of identification
shows their age and that they're of good
professional character which is easier
and so it allows
uh apprentices to
start and to work with
um as apprenticeships in the program and
the board retains the authority to set
the rules and once they complete the
this any questions if so please raise
your
hand I see none does anyone else wish to
goalie thank you Mr chair uh just a
quick question as we had had a bill uh
dealing with this subject in committee
prior that is on its way to the Senate
um the languages do not mirror each
pass that's a excellent question and I
think it will be a an issue
um the part about the
school or a section of a school program
within a school is unique to the LIC to
this bill and it wouldn't be affected
either way
um the rest of it I I you have
identified an issue that needs to be
you
um Mr brri did you add your hand up
would you like to speak you should be
able to unmute
yourself right thank you very much and
and good afternoon chairman and members
of the committee so for the record I'm
Tom Brodrick legal counsel at the office
of professional lure and certification
or oplc um and as you know the oplc
provides administrative and clerical
support um for the approximately or the
for the 54 occupational licensing boards
commissions and councils under our
umbrella so I'm here now to speak on
Section 11 of SB 133 uh be begins on the
bottom of page 49 and ends on the page
50 um this bill affects the Board of
barbering cosmetology and Aesthetics but
I want to make clear right now I'm
speaking on behalf of the board not or
sorry of the oplc the agency not the
board I've consulted with the board on
this process they're aware of this um
but I'm speaking for the agency so oplc
actually we requested this change after
consultation with the board really to
fix and or to clarifi clarify two issues
with the board's Practice Act both
issues concerns the board's authority to
regulate programs within high schools so
the board actually currently licenses
Independent Schools um such as Tom
Brodrick School of Barbering um but it
also licenses a few programs within high
schools so for instance conquered high
school has a cosmetology program where
students get an apprentice license from
the board and learn cos mology at the
high school the first issue that this
legislation is seeking to resolve is
clarification as to whether the board
has the authority to license and
regulate programs within high schools
rather than just Independent Schools um
as I mentioned earlier the board
currently does so and has for a long
time um the confusion comes from uh a
discrepancy between the definition of
school in RSA 3113
a112 which is Broad um and reads just
School means a school or other
institution conducted for the purpose of
teaching cosmetology manicuring
barbering or Aesthetics versus RSA 313
a72 which reads the board May license a
school to operate postsecondary programs
including post-secondary programs
leading to a certificate in barbering
cosmetology and Aesthetics so
um we have one statute that that says
the board May license
schools and schools are Broad and then
another statute that says they may
license schools to operate postsecondary
programs and um
so in this bill Pages L uh page 49 lines
23 21 through 33 are really seeking to
resolve the ambiguity and make clear
that the board may may continue to
license and regulate the programs within
the high
schools um the second issue that this
legislation is seeking to resolve is a
little bit more complicated so the the
child protection statute 161
b16a oplc and really any other state
agency is required to collect the social
security number of any applicant for a
professional license um but for these
students specifically the students
within high schools um within public
high schools under I believe it's furpa
um the school the school cannot require
a student to provide their social
security number so we have a bit of a
catch 20
where the school cannot require cannot
request a social security number um but
the board must require it if if we're
saying these students need to have an
apprentice license with the board or
Apprentice certificate with the board um
so the remainder of this bill which is
page 49 lines 34 to page 50 lines 23 is
meant to fix this issue um so in short
that section is meant to exempt those
applying for these Apprentice
certificates from the requirement to
provide a social security number um that
concludes my public testimony the one
thing I'll add is representative goalie
I was unable to hear your question um
because I was being promoted to panelist
so um if there's something I can answer
I'm happy to to do my best
questions representative goie yes I just
want to repeat my uh statement or my
question was that if this and the bill
that was currently before the house
committee that's off into the Senate
dealing with the sub subject matter both
issue all right I um it I'm not clear on
which bill that is but I'm happy to I
believe it's House Bill
575 all right I'm I'm happy to look into
that and get back to the committee okay
questions representative
fellows um thank you uh can you tell
me does oplc or the board board of um
you know barbering and
cosmetology cosmetology did they approve
the program the schools and the programs
that are in
schools um they yes the the board not
oplc the the board approves schools and
has um curriculum requirements set via
rules okay so thank you so my followup
followup so my my other question is how
does
this work
with approvals made by the Department of
Education of vocational
programs how do those two things work
together um I would have to get back to
you on that I I know I've looked into
that a little bit for the electricians
who have have some vog programs and also
the board I haven't specifically looked
cosmetology and I I have one more
follow-up question followup yeah um
right now
do the students who graduate from
those high school vocational programs
how did they go about getting their
apprentice license do they just get it
automatically because they completed the
program or what I believe um I believe
when I believe they get their apprentice
license when they're in the program and
that's actually leading to one of the
issues is um to get their apprentice
license they are supposed to give us
their social security number but the
school cannot ask for their social
furpa any those licenses are you giving
them those licenses right
now I I believe we are I need to double
check with administrator but I believe
we are okay thank
you any further
questions
I don't see any does anyone else want to
s133 see none I'm going to close the
section all right part 12
um again that's Senator Reagan and I
have you managed to get a hold of
missling
him
co-sponsors Senator Carson senat is
Hennessy no we have no Senators left
right in that case
[Music]
um representative Alro would you
introduce
get
okay I don't believe I need to say more
than this is part 12 of s SP 133
relative to me tele medicine provided by
out ofate psychologists am I clear on it
thank
Warner
you should be able to unmute yourself
Dr Warner do you un mute yourself and
us
her
well is there anyone else who wishes to
yes Mr
brck uh good afternoon again uh members
of the committee and uh maybe I I know
Dr Warner wants to testify as well so
maybe this will give her time to um
unmute but U again for the record I'm
Tom Brodrick legal counsil of OPC uh I'm
speaking now on behalf of the oplc not
the board of psychologists I believe Dr
Warner is here to speak um from that
perspective um
so uh I wanted to testify today to to
put forward the oplc we're really
neutral on this piece of legislation uh
the reason I'm here is to provide an
explanation of the bill and its effect
on the in administration the board which
is um the administration the board is
opl's charge so this piece of
legislation creates a new license
category a New Hampshire telepath the
intention of which is to allow out ofate
Psych ologists an easier way to provide
Psy psychologist Services via remote
technology in New Hampshire um as of now
there's there's currently two ways that
individuals from another state can
provide teles Psychology Services in New
Hampshire first they can go through the
regular lure process to get license here
in New Hampshire um that is a lengthier
process or or two New Hampshire has
joined the interstate compact uh cact I
know we've heard a lot of about compacts
today um so if there home state is also
a member of cypa they can obtain the
interstate compact license and come here
or and practice in New Hampshire which
includes tele telepractice so this would
really create a third Third Avenue um
the main effect on opl's Administration
the boards are as follows so first as I
mentioned earlier it creates an entirely
new lure category it it is an increased
administrative burden as it involves
granting a new set of initial licenses
renewals um drafting new rules for this
process
um we're not oplc is not necessarily
against the bill for this reason and we
of course we'll implement it if the bill
is passed um we want to make wanted to
make this committee aware though
um second uh opl's second effect uh
dovetails with this so the the board
joined the interstate compact in
September 2019 less than two years ago
uh it last I checked 14 states joined it
might be 16
uh and are active in the compact
um I think one more has joined but the
legislation isn't yet effective and 13
more states are pending legislation this
year so that's 28 States um from what
we've seen with other compacts the
number of states that joined once a
compact meets that threshold uh that
initial threshold to become active um
will only be will only increase so for
lies coming from these compact seates
the bill is largely unnecessary and
redundant um and may actually be more
confusing to individuals I do understand
that um this tella Health would likely
have a lower fee than a compact fee um
but it isn't redundant for those from
non-compact States um so um and just
lastly I know my executive director
Lindsay Courtney has spoken to uh Dr
Warner and she may be testifying and um
again I want to make clear we are we're
neutral on this bill um but we did want
the committee to know those two pieces
so this concludes my testimony um happy
to take any questions representative
schelz thank you um and thank you for
taking my question um so I think I
understand what you're saying obviously
you're one part is your you oplc is not
taking a formal stand on this but this
um telepass
um it sounds like something that
um might be too specific is that fair to
say it seems like by naming it and
calling it out as telepath and I assume
it's not in any rsas at this point um
that that type of Licensing process it
sounds like it's something that's
temporary or I don't know what the word
would be but maybe just too specific
does my question does that make sense my
question make sense so I I think Dr
Warner can probably testify to this um
with more um eloquence than I can
probably but my understanding it's not
temporary um but it is intended to allow
people to
um you know if you're a psychologist in
Massachusetts and your patient comes up
to New Hampshire um and they need to do
a session with you online you could use
rather than getting a full New Hampshire
license or going through this compact
I'm not sure if Massachusetts is a
member of the compact they could more
easily get this T telepass license and
followup Madam chair followup and it is
my understanding that the executive
order that allows for various Health
Care to occur via tele medicine already
covers this at least
temporarily um I I believe it does but
the emergency order that would only be
valid during the pendency of the
does other questions for Mr
Brer in that case Dr Warner H yes thank
you so much I I am sorry I had a
technical issue uh just as you uh
allowed my computer
to um on so um I do have comments on
this the yourself first can can you hear
me all right we can hear you just fine
please introduce yourself first before
going into your testimony yes thank you
so much I'm a little flustered because
my whole computer just went oh went
funny and I'm on my iPad now um I'm Dr
Debbie Warner I'm in Littleton New
Hampshire I serve on the board of Psy
psychologists I'm the vice chair and I
come here representing the board uh we
did author this section of the bill the
part Roman 12 and um we felt we had very
good reason for that we appreciate
Senator Reagan bringing this forward for
us and uh just as he did previously
bring forth cypa on our behalf I we are
doing
cack and as for compacts uh it is good
to get in on the ground floor if we can
send a rule nerd into the midst and I
happen to be that little rule nerd as
you are well aware um and so cypac is
progressing and they are developing good
rules we do have a little gap between
what we're doing very well we like these
emergency licenses actually uh they make
it very easy for somebody to very
quickly uh come in and follow their
patients into New Hampshire whether or
not they are uh students who've come
home from school or visitors or
snowbirds or U maybe visiting family who
have come to New Hampshire to deal with
a family crisis perhaps and they want to
retain continuity with their care back
home those are all very very good uses
for this little telepath license which
is basically almost the same format as
our emergency licenses that are
happening during Co
which we like uh we were appreciative of
how that went so swiftly now cypa itself
is a big deal it takes about three or
four months to get your credentials
through cypa and it costs
$440 and that's fine you're going to get
a lot of states in that currently There
are 16 States in our cact Compact and
there so that least 34 states that are
not and and uh this little telip pass
would take care of that and that people
who just want a little mini license and
come in it is unlimited for the year in
terms of the way we see it uh in terms
of time and number of sessions but it is
just teley medicine and it is meant for
uh reaching into the state um by
licensed doctors of
psychology now um there are some
questions that I heard previously do you
know about um compliance and what
quality of folks you're getting we are
make making sure that it is at the
doctoral level um that they come in and
they have
to a test that they have a clean license
and no issues on their license and no
discipline and that we can do this very
quickly administratively and oplc is
getting quite Dandy at the online
licensing and renewals and things and so
we're hoping that it would be
instantaneous that if somebody you're
following goes into the state that you
can take care of them um for a low price
it's not very difficult to evaluate
these and if somebody happens to lie and
say that they have a clean license but
they don't they will be in such super
trouble uh that it is really not worth
lying um when we check it the next
business day or two and find out if
they're wrong they're going to get a
very severe penalty in their home state
for uh probably a revocation uh we would
put in our rules that we would have to
construct that you would be revoked if
you lied on your application like that
um we are hoping that this is uh easy to
administer as we haven't heard any
complaints from oplc about their
administrating the emergency licenses
and so we think it will be very Dandy in
that that way we also um looking for a
low price very quick and very uh very
helpful this will only benefit the
citizens of New Hampshire and the
visitors who come here it doesn't it
benefit the psychologists who are
licensed in New Hampshire because
actually it's going to increase the pool
of talent available to draw upon but we
do have a number of Specialties that
we're a little sparse at and so it would
be very nice to be able to draw on from
other states and people could it might
just be one of those New Hampshire
advantages that we get to have um a
broader uh spectrum of providers be able
to help us here in New Hampshire so if
you were going to for example get a
specialty care out of New York or Boston
or wherever it might be and you can
entice them to pay that extra perhaps
$100 and come and help you here uh with
very little difficulty on their part I
think that we would find that it's very
very helpful to our people I've talked
with the um board um administrators from
some of the neighboring states and they
want to see how this goes if we take it
on maybe they will too and bring that
forward and we can have just sort of a a
nice neighborhood of um reciprocal care
and we don't have any other real
reciprocity with other states at this
point in time now I can speak on this
bill with the authority of the board of
psychologists I am also as I indicated I
am the commissioner uh from New
Hampshire for
cypa and um I can answer questions about
cypac but I'm not their spokesperson per
se I can just talk as your commissioner
U and give you feedback uh those are my
points and um be happy to take questions
thank you thank you we will be having a
subcommittee on this next Thursday and
we delighted if you could call in
and I'm sorry did you say next Thursday
there's the committee yes sub commmittee
I that's a little tough for me but what
time would that
be uh afternoon I
imagine okay I if I could get that
information early that would be very
helpful I'll put that make sure that I
can do that okay I will the subcommittee
chair will will let you know when he
plans to take it up representative sh
you have a
question yes thank you madam chair um
thank you for taking my question Dr
Warner I'm I'm a little bit confused
about
um at one point you said the cost for
CPA was around uh I believe you said
$440 towards the end of your testimony
you said that there was or you alluded
to it multiple parts of your testimony
but I'm a little confused something that
is smaller than that like a shortterm or
specific by client type of
sidea
yes yes I should clarify cypa is
different than this
bill this bill is to bring forward our
very own New Hampshire brand of Telly
pass license which is only for telly
medicine it's only for licensed
psychologists at the doctoral level from
other states and we take the money and
we process it and one thing we do like
about this is that they follow our rules
our laws and they're administrated by
our board we don't have to go through
that other structure which is the cact
commission and all of that um business
at the the national uh Association level
um so this fills in that Gap that takes
so that we can
and have access that's quick and proper
and that we have jurisdiction good
jurisdiction over their practice um but
it in terms of the provider the provider
would like it probably because we will
have a low price on this simple license
as opposed to paying
$440 to cact and you get 16 States for
that but if your patient didn't go to
that state what do you
do so we're we're trying to fill a
little niche there it's it's not in
competition with sidea but it's just a
niche in
between and Madam chair I have a
followup followup so you mentioned too
that there were conditions that um the
available
practitioners are um low in number and
some cases maybe not in existence would
you believe that I have one of those
conditions and during the executive
order that allowed for tele medicine I
was able to reconnect with my therapist
from 13 years ago and finally get the
care I
needed so this would benefit you that
your therapist could pay their small fee
whatever oplc will set perhaps $100 and
U be able to continue on with your Care
thank you thank you Dr
Warner which of our adjoining or New
England states
are in
CA we don't have any neighbors in cypa
thank you our closest neighbor I think
is Delaware I think Pennsylvania's on
its way
in thank you that's what I
thought are there any other questions
Warner seeing none thank you very much
for your
testimony thank you very much for having
me and is there any anyone else who
do any all right in that case I will
close the hearing on Part 12 and open
the hearing on part
13 and last and I believe that's Senator
guis is he with us miss Marling he is
and I just um promoted him there he is
okay Senator
G good afternoon members of the
committee I am very obviously not
Senator G I am Griffin robers his
legislative Aid um I just texted him he
is coming out of a meeting and he should
be here within the next two minutes so
if you'll just bear with me I'll get him
moments
impressive
while we're waiting for Senator GAA I'll
just remind people that tomorrow re of
scitec subcommittee will be meeting in
the morning on Section seven which is
uh the rule writing authority of
oplc and at in the afternoon
representative Roy subcommittee will be
meeting on sections two and five which
are about the the
compacts a question of the chair yes sir
so uh I'm not appointed to any of the
subcommittees but I take it that we are
all allowed to sit in so to speak even
though we wouldn't be allowed
vote Yes all of the committee are are
welcome to attend the subcommittee
and will be able to participate but not
vote as representative
said okay there Senator guided well I
didn't actually say participate I said
sit in but thank you that I was about to
follow up with that question participate
is what it's at thank you Senator G good
afternoon thank you m Madam chair
members of the committee for the record
Bob G Senate District 2 uh and Prime
sponsor of part 13 of Senate Bill 133 FN
as amended by the
Senate uh this bill grew out of uh a
rule passed by uh the um Food Services
Division of Public Health uh well
intended by adopting a federal standard
that would require a certified food
protection manager to be on
during working hours for any food
facility at all in the
State uh obviously uh in the interest of
safety I can understand and respect uh
that been a very low incidence of food
poisoning incidents uh as demonstrated
by their own data uh but the concern
here is that there are a number of small
food establishments and that the $300
fee for becoming certified uh by a
private agency recognized by the state
uh becomes onerous when one considers
the turnover in employees which is high
in the food service industry uh and
thereby bringing very significant
additional costs as a requirement to
even open your doors and so what this
bill does uh it it it exempts small
establishments um the restaurant uh and
and hotel uh organization is supporting
this HHS worked with us to develop this
um it takes uh it still makes the
establishments responsible makes them
have a person in charge that's a
certified food safety manager um still
has the responsibilties and obligation
exempt certain types of food preparation
such as
reheating uh and at the same time
mitigates the uh the significant expense
with the high turnover of $300 per
certification employees uh that just
under the uh rulemaking that uh to their
credit uh they have not um vigorously
enforced uh due due to the pandemic uh
and also due to their understanding of
uh the fact that uh this is onerous on
the small businesses I'm happy to
address section by section uh but it's
pretty pretty clear there is currently
only one section that's a11 under 143
this would add
A1A um a certified food protection
manager section and with that Madam
chair I will take any questions thank
you Senator are there
questions representative
scitec Senator G you said uh reheating
is
Exempted I'm sorry I I can't hear you
sir I'm sorry uh reheating is Exempted
does that mean McDonald's is off the
hook on
this let me read the exact language if
um
well where let me tell you where 14 let
me tell you where I'm going does this
mean if I go into today into the Common
Man or McDonald's if it's not reheating
they have a certified food uh uh prot
protection manager on somebody certified
standing there while that's correct they
they either do or will shortly be
required to I think that's more up to
the uh to the call of HHS uh as I said
they've been lenient in the of this
understanding the pandemic and you know
the slam that small businesses
especially small eing establishments
have taken but this will be a
requirement that uh um you know the
larger establishments that have you know
uh five or 10 cook staff and then 20 or
30 weight staff won't have a problem
with this uh but the smaller
establishments with with fewer people uh
with a high turnover rate it becomes a
significant cost to them and that's the
reason for this legislation if you say
so
okay uh representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair uh good
good afternoon Senator uh so you said
such as reheating uh do you list all of
the exempt uh
activities well if you read the bill sir
you'll find that they're in there okay
um and I'm happy to do that having at
least um the requirement shall not apply
under these conditions one food
establishments having at least one
certified food protection manager on
staff shall not be required to have the
certified food protection manager
present when no food preparation is
taking place thank you Senator we
appreciate your offer but I think
representative Schmidt can read read the
bill he's he's shown his his literacy on
many previous
occasions thank you m chair do that
equate to a gold Shar Madam chair you
beta thank you Senator certainly Peter
thank you are there any other questions
I don't see any so thank you again thank
you madam chair members of the committee
uh I do appreciate your consideration
and hope we can look for an a to pass
with this have a good
afternoon is there anyone else who
people
silin Mr San you can unmute yourself and
uh speak to
us well good afternoon everyone um my
name is um Mike silin from Aroma Joe's
Coffee I I would like to uh thk thank
both uh mad Mr co-chairs um for their
time this afternoon in the entire
committee um and thank you Senator GAA
for um listening to us uh early on last
year and and adding this um legislative
to this um Bill we are in complete
support of SB 133 part 13 and I'd like
everyone to understand um I'm one of the
original Founders there was four cousins
um from Southern Maine that created the
Aroma Joe's brand back in 2000 um I
currently own and operate 19 stores
locally with my brother Brian um 13 of
those are in New Hampshire we have 75
stores open and operating right now in
five states on the East Coast 37 of
those stores are in New Hampshire um so
right now the state represents about
half of our um brand as far as open and
operating and we currently have just
myself and my brother um upwards of 270
employees in New Hampshire if you take
into um if you take into account those
are only 13 of the 37 we have well north
of
550 employees right now in the state um
with eight additional stores in
development um in New Hampshire alone
over the next 18 to 24 months um I want
everyone to understand that um our
Workforce is made up um mostly
of young high school and college um kids
this is their first job that they
receive um in some cases we are teaching
them how to mop um how to wash dishes
for the first time it is it is
incredibly uh burdensome to ask them now
to take a food manager level
certification there is no need for these
um young kids who who we work around
their school schedules we work around
their school sports schedules all their
uh extracurricular activity we we are
really looking to build
um solid Workforce kids like entering
entering into the the workforce in in
the in New Hampshire in their
surrounding states um asking them to
learn what the correct temperature is to
store or serve shellfish or chicken or
how to refuse uh damaged cardboard all
of which does not fit our business model
whatsoever I have provided written
testimony um to the senate committee
that did pass and support this bill and
I'd be happy to share that information
with the house and this particular
committee to understand the financial
burden on this this course is incredibly
difficult to pass the first time it does
they don't charge as much to try to
attempt to pass the second time but in
our experience only a 40% um passing
rate happens the first time uh and
unfortunately I just found out today
that uh Serve Safe increased their cost
for this Co um course by 8% so all my
numbers that I've previously submitted
to Senator GAA and his team um are
already 8% too low just just for the 13
stores that I operate this would this
results in about an $80,000 a year uh
cost to me and once these kids have it
they can carry that on with them and
take them to other places or other
establishments um and I want we do not s
we do not serve food from a raw State um
all of it is thaw and serve or all of it
is heat uh reheated in store we're we're
not hand handling um raw products to the
consumer and it's one thing when you're
serving
three4 cups of coffee or energy drinks
in a dut it's that's much different than
serving 24 $30 plates of of seafood or
chicken or steak so I I believe the
intent was good I I I mirror um Senator
gaa's um uh sentiment that um HHS has
worked with us and and and changed the
verbiage to to fit businesses like
myself that we are requiring food
handler certifications from our staff um
which is which is plenty we still have
food manager certification people on
staff at each store they are available
for all the hours that we're open but
they're not there physically on site and
and I think if everyone would read um
the language in this part 13 um they'll
understand that that this is a great
compromise and it uh it actually serves
out the intent of when HHS adopted the
2017 FDA Food Code standards rule I
think we've we've done a great job here
getting um the intent um implemented and
again I want to thank any thank everyone
for their time and I'm here to answer
any questions if there are
questions Mr San U one of my students
works at your Salem in or uh Dairy Store
you're working her too many hours it's
hurting her
grade I don't that's relevant
represent I'm sorry sir hey find us find
us some more great willing to work great
kids and I'd be more than happy to
employ some more of
them representative
fellows um yes I would thank you madam
chair I would just um like to ask the
person testifying um if he could repeat
what the license that um or certificate
they already have is food handlers is
that that that's that's correct uh
representative fellows what we did so
that everyone understands pre we were
dealing with this issue preco um in that
in those discussions um we were HHS
allowed us to apply for and we received
a variance waiver for this particular
rule so there are some cities that we
operate in that that self-inspect and
there are other cities in towns and
municipalities in the state that have
that rely on state inspectors well we
applied for and received a waiver
variant part of our waiver variance
representative is that we because we are
a growing brand and because we have 75
stores we do self monthly self
inspections of all of our stores we make
sure that they are clean we make sure
that all the equipment's operating
properly we make sure that the
temperatures are correct we make sure of
all those things and we provided all
that information to HHS and in addition
to that we are requiring all of our
employees as part of their onboarding
training to take a ServSafe food handler
certificate it's a $15 course
it's much much um more geared toward
what these kids will be dealing with
temperature safety
hygiene um allergens it's it it's the
meat and potatoes of working in the food
service industry it's not the technical
long drawn out six-hour course it's a
two-hour course that much more um aligns
with the business model that we run and
that one is is is very um informative
much easier to pass and much more
affordable in what I feel suits our our
business model much
better um followup followup uh thank you
so this this certificate that that all
that your employees are getting is that
that doesn't fall under the state lure
is that correct is that from my
independent source
and there's no State requirement for
that or not is that not
correct it it is my understanding right
now that that is not a state requirement
it is one thing that we're doing to go
above and beyond the requirement to
prove that we understand the attent of
adopting this rule but we have a better
way and a more structured and it fits
our business model better but the food
handler certificate in in my experience
is not required at any state level
thank
you other representative schs mam chair
my question is actually for you one of
my classic dumb questions um and I do
appreciate uh Mr San's testimony my
question is is it safe to say that this
topic is probably very well understood
in one of the other committees like
Commerce or
HHS especially if these requirements are
new uh it's possible but uh it's it's
close
enough okay I just feel like the
expertise on this topic is probably I
mean some of us have it personally but
you know if they if these requirements
are fairly new and the implementation
around those requirements were already
underway with another committee I just
think it would be helpful to hear from
someone from that committee I would
suggest think think that the Committee
involved would be
HHS they have already committed to
contacting them about section8 so I will
mention this one as well thank
you and the next there are no more
questions from Mr San I'd like to call
colen Smith from
HHS good afternoon chair Maguire and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Colleen Smith and I'm the
administrator of the food protection SE
ction within the Department of Health
and Human Services Division of Public
Health Services I want to thank the
community for committee for the
opportunity to speak in support of
section 13 of Senate Bill 133 regarding
the program rules within DHHS for the
sanitary production and distribution of
food the department has worked closely
with Senator GAA on this bill as amended
to address concerns with the
Department's food protection regulations
in particular the certified food
protection manager requirement this
became a requirement when we uh updated
our program rules to incorporate the
latest version of the US uh US Food and
Drug administration's F 2017 food code
in August of
2019 this bill as amended addresses the
concern of hardship to small businesses
while we uh feel that there is a very
import there is importance to having
that certified food protection manager
on staff we feel that we have crafted a
bill that provi allows flexibility for
certain low-risk businesses when food
preparation is limited to reheating
commercially prepared food handling
ready to eat food only or when this food
establishment has five food employees or
less on duty as long as there's already
one certified food protection manager on
staff I I also want to note the the
department has also started a rule
making process to amend our
administrative rules to line with the
changes proposed in SB 133 and we're
hoping that those rules will go before
the New Hampshire joint legislative
committee on administrative rules within
the next few months uh thank you again
for allowing me to speak to this bill
and I'm happy to take any questions that
you may have uh I have a question how
can you revise the rules if you don't
have the statutory Authority so we uh we
had um believe that we did have within
our rules we had already had some
exemptions to the certified food
protection manager requirement so um
along with the with this legislation we
had concurrently started to update our
rules um we haven't we just um submitted
that fiscal impact statement we haven't
had the public hearing but we had we had
worked um both path past knowing this
legislation was in progress um and we
had um worked with Senator GAA and had
spoke with him about doing Ru making as
well I see uh representative Schmidt you
have a question I do indeed thank you
madam chair so miss uh Smith I believe
Colleen I'll call you so
uh certified Foods uh protection on
staff I believe you said uh AR Roman
Joe's the example we were just dealing
with uh doesn't sound really like a
small business if they have a hundred or
so establishments all over the place but
they're individually small I understand
that uh how would this food service
protection uh train Serv I've got the
title wrong but you know what I'm
talking about uh how is this person
going to be able
to um to to take care of that
responsibility with hundreds of small
establishments they're they're tiny
we've got several here in
do uh yes so and Mr senen if if um he
would like to also CH chime in with
regard to this you um they do have a
certified food protection manager on
staff already um as as he had explained
um this will help his model um you know
certainly those those later hours maybe
that 5 to9 shift when that certified
food protection manager wouldn't be
present on um at the store but certainly
available by phone if if there was a
situation that that they were needed
followup followup I I I understand that
that that uh that they would have such a
person on staff but the question is uh
this person H how would the protection
aspect work with uh dozens and in in the
state of New Hampshire Alone
um uh how would this person be able to
oversee conditions in the individual
shops so having that that individual on
staff the expectation is that that the
restaurant or food establishment has
policies and procedures that are
protective during all hours of of um the
operation whether it be allergen control
whether it be San ation practices
whether it be employee health and
hygiene so the having that higher level
certified person on staff the idea is
even in in ours when there is a lower
risk operation happening that those you
know prerequisite policies and
procedures would still be carried
carried forward even in the absence of
that person being physically on site and
this this aspect is something follow up
and this this aspect is something that
you have thoroughly thought
through yes we believe that that this
that there are um that there are certain
instances where we can allow some
flexibility you know and certainly if we
um you know through an inspection
process find
volitive um situations time after time
again we can always make that
recommendation that they have um that
certified food protection manager
present during longer times but but um
we're hopeful that with um with what we
have crafted is that uh we won't be in
that
situation um at all okay thank you sure
representative
goalie thank you madam chair I just want
to follow up on the chair's question in
regards to rulemaking so is there Ru
making currently in is it in the process
um to address this
issue yes we have started Ed Ru making
that would have um very it would have
mirror the language that's presented in
this
bill followup
followup is it normal practice to do Ru
adopted so we had um in our discussions
with Senator GAA we had um said that we
were plan you know since we've been
working on updating this Rule and
crafting the language for several months
now and not knowing what was going to be
um the outcome of this bill so we wanted
to have both options
available followup followup so can this
place this this language into the
statute so that um that would be again
we haven't gone through the full r Ru
making process the public hearing
process but but certainly um I I think
there is a pathway for both both Avenues
whether it be in in legis in in a
statute or in
questions representative fellows thank
you madam chair
um just a on the same lines that um
we've been speaking do you anticipate
that the rules will have some kind of
guidelines for these situations when the
um person needs to be an an employee but
doesn't need to be on site for example
will it say that they need to inspect
once a week or something along that
line so we have not put in that type of
detail in our proposed rule right now
the the language that we are proposing
in rule is is very much um mirroring
questions does anyone else wish to
hand gets their bills
change
employees thank you represent sitech for
that
correction I don't see any hands up so
no since no one else seems to want to
speak is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on a pre section that didn't get
to still no hands so I will close the
public hearing thank you all for lasting
through it and the subcommittees will
tomorrow question of the chair yes sir
so uh are
we obviously we didn't hear from Senator
Reagan in spite of our best efforts uh
do we have any any Outreach to him with
regard to any remarks he would have made
available I think his constituent
and U Miss Smith probably said as much
have well I know I appreciate the
technical expertise from Mr San and Miss
Smith entirely just that you know we
certainly made our best effort to try to
contact senator
Reagan
yes can I Madam chair quick question
Miss Smith are you still there we have a
question from representative scitech I'm
just wonder isn't this current practice
I mean this is the way things are
operating right now in New Hampshire
right
well
I guess not she may have left sorry
sorry I yes I
sorry chair McGuire I am available to
answer any additional questions okay
reopening the hearing so would you would
you explain if this is current practice
or not there I didn't mean to reopen the
hearing I just take advantage of the
fact that you're here isn't this current
practice people aren't you know we
haven't had youth mentioned there's
really been no
issues that correct
I I'm so I'm sorry just looking for some
clarification no issues on uh on the
enforcing the
requirement in the in the area touched
by this bill are you having problem
problems with restaurants uh with uh
that with food poisoning with issues I
mean it seems things seem to be running
so I mean I mean this is a casual after
the casual conversation after the
hearing it's too bad it's like this but
this is chat what I'm I
just why is this happening why is it
still happening because the feds the
feds
wanted the 2017 FDA rules that's why we
have mushroom LIC mushroom Harvest LIC
yes uh representative Pearson listen
to Madam chair uh I'm just looking could
you remind uh all of us on Edna which
which parts of this are assigned to
which subcommittees and I just got
reminded that we didn't meet the 24hour
notice so tomorrow morning section seven
will be with the represent scitec
subcommittee and section five will with
representative Roy's
subcommittee and the rest will be with
representative
yakubovich's subcommittee
next next Thursday
yes right did um just to be clear
section two I thought you moved to
somebody else is that still same tried I
tried to but it doesn't meet the 24hour
notice for subcommittee work session so
it will remain with representative
yakubovich next week very good thank you
okay um representative O'Brian do you
have a
question uh thank you Madame chair uh
when did you say uh part seven was going
to be discussed because I do have a
doctor's appointment tomorrow 10 AM 10
AM uh would it be okay to leave early or
do you see a difficulty and if there is
a difficulty I may has to be uh replaced
the appointment is in Boston
unfortunately okay well we will it it is
just a subcommittee so we
will be glad to have you for as long as
you can you can attend I thank the chair
psych representative Fells thank you
madam chair I had a question question
about the anticipated schedule for the
uh subcommittees to wrap up all their
work because I'm on the one that has the
almost all the bills in it and we don't
have our first meeting until next week
yes well the main point is
that you need to look at is this section
necessary and if so is it correct so if
you can finish your work that day great
if not
we'll have to continue it to some later
date okay thank
you and Madam chair I have a question
regarding the bills that we retained
because um when do you think you'll be
assigning
um you know are you going to assign
subcommittees to those retained bills
they have all been subcommittees have
been assigned and the notice went out uh
several weeks ago
actually okay one once we're through
with the Senate bills I'll issue an
updated list including any Senate bills
you may be
retaining and the ruling we have from
the speaker is that once we have once
we're through with our Senate bills we
can start working on retain bills and I
would strongly recommend that we meet at
least once in May or June in order to
scope out the work we want to do on the
retain B thank you some of them may need
research or something else and we'd like
early and Miriam would have sent that
schedule out I'll resend it thank you
subcommittee chairs have to read the
script G do that same yes you have to
read the script and in fact I just got a
notice from uh barium on how to run a
subcommittee that I send to the
subcommittee chairs be exciting it'll be
it'll be thrilling we'll all get a
chance to learn the script
wow that's true I'll send
did actually no she didn't send it to
issues in that case have a nice evening
and those of us on the representative
sitech committee will be here uh
tomorrow morning I'll remind
representative Schmid he's welcome to